welcome to the world of excel Mastery in
this comprehensive course we will start
a journey to unlock the full potential
of Microsoft Excel whether you're
beginner looking to learn the basics or
a Season Pro aiming to sharpen your
skills then this course has something
for everyone from creating captivating
spreadsheets to automating complex tasks
with formulas and macros you will gain
the expertise need needed to excel in
your personal and professional Endeavors
get ready to transform data into
valuable insights streamline workflows
and become an Excel wizard let's dive in
and harness the power of this
indispensable tool we will also uncover
some time-saving tips and tricks
enabling you to streamline your
workflows and boost your productivity
whether you are a business professional
data analyst or simply seeking to
enhance your excess skills this course
is your gateway to becoming an expert in
leveraging excel's advanced capabilities
get ready to unlock the full potential
of Excel and revolutionalize your data
analysis Journey as we speak you might
wonder what it takes to become an expert
data analyst if you are an aspiring data
analyst with at least one year of domain
experience and looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leaving experts then
search no more simply learns
postgraduate program in data analysis
from per University in collaboration
with IBM should be your right choice for
more details on this course head
straight to our homepage and type in
postgraduate program and data analysis
or simply click on the link in the
description box below with that in mind
over to our training experts what is
Microsoft Excel so Microsoft Excel is a
software product designed and developed
by Microsoft is storing data in an
organized way that is rows and columns
and Microsoft Excel is also capable to
manipulate data through some
mathematical
operations followed by that Microsoft
Excel is also used to extract the
insights from the data and represent it
in the form of visually appealing graphs
and charts now we have a basic
understanding or an overview of what a
Microsoft Excel software product is now
moving ahead we will understand the
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel so
following are some fundamentals that you
need to know before getting started with
Microsoft Excel so basically when
install the Microsoft Office in your
computer you will have various Microsoft
products out of which Microsoft Excel is
one of the product so we will be dealing
exactly with that particular product
that is Microsoft Excel so when you get
started with Microsoft Excel this is
what you will see in the first page so
this particular page is called as
Microsoft Excel homepage where you will
be having various varieties of sheets
Microsoft Excel will give you some
suggestions based on the type of sheet
you want to work with we will see this
in a better way way through the
Practical session so once you get
started with the sheet you will have
some more options so this particular
option is called as the tool bar menu
you will have the file home insert draw
page layout formulas data review View
and help so these are the tools that you
will be using to work on your data using
Microsoft Excel furthermore we have a
toolbar ribbon so when you select some
of the other option from the file home
insert draw page layout formulas data
review View and help buttons you will
have a ribbon so for example you can see
that I have selected the Home Tool here
so when I press on the Home Tool this is
the ribbon which Microsoft Excel gives
me so this ribbon has some options in it
which can perform various operations now
in a further more detailed way we will
have toolbar groups so when you see in
the previous slide we have a complete
toolbar ribbon so this particular ribbon
is segmented into groups so you can see
the first group as paste Cut Copy format
painter etc etc and the second group is
the font the size of the font and to
increase the size of the font to
decrease the size of the font bold
italic underline etc etc and here you
can see the text alignment so each and
every group has separate functions so
each set is called as a
group and I think you can see a small
Arrow option over here so this Arrow
option is used into the toolbar groups
when the group is not able to fit all
the operations or all the
functionalities in one single provided
section so when you click on this
particular Arrow Mark you will have
another dialog box so this is called
toolbar more options so you can see that
when I clicked on this icon you can see
a new dialogue box which opens me a new
set of operations which are not able to
be fit in this particular group so we
will also see more about this in a
better way in the Practical session now
moving forward we have cell and address
so when you open a Microsoft Excel sheet
you can find boxes so each and every box
is named as a cell and each cell has its
own address for example the highlighted
cell over here has an address B3 so B is
the column name and three is the rule
name and apart from that you can have
the sheet tracker in the bottom left
corner of the Excel sheet where you can
navigate through different sheets and in
the bottom right corner you have an
option of increasing or inreasing the
sheet size so these are the basic
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel that you
need to keep in mind before getting
started so we will have more on this in
the Practical session if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more so
now we enter the demo inventory in
Microsoft Excel so we will be using
Microsoft Excel to create a sheet of the
employees in a company so basically an
employee in a company has employee ID
name and designation salary etc etc so
we will be trying to create the same
table using Microsoft Excel but before
that let us understand the fundamentals
of Microsoft Excel through the Practical
demo first so I have started my
Microsoft Excel and this is how the
homepage of Microsoft Excel looks like
so you have a blank workbook over here
if you want to create a new workbook you
can select new Option so Excel will
provide you with various variety of
sheets you can see money in Excel
adjustable meeting agenda streaming
showers small business cash flow and
many more if you're not able to find
what your looking for then you always
have an option of selecting the
particular type of sheet what you're
looking for so you have various options
if it's business if it's personal if
it's planners and trackers list budgets
charts etc etc so let's imagine that you
wanted something from business so just
by clicking at business option the Excel
will load a variety of sheets related to
business options so this might take a
while so you can see that the Excel is
loading few types of
sheets so you can see that Excel has
provided us with some online varieties
of sheets for example any calendar
business expenses Channel marketing
budget budget summary report blue
product list etc etc you can see
construction proposal enro your name it
Excel has CED so Excel will provide you
with some variety of options based on
your requirement now for this session
let's get started with a plank workbook
which looks something like this since
this tutorial is based on the
fundamentals we'll go with the blank
workbook now over here you can see the
toolbar that we discussed earlier that
has the file home insert draw page
layout formulas data review View and
help so this is the toolbar and under
the toolbar I have selected home and you
can see this is the particular ribbon
what we discussed about this particular
ribbon belongs to homepage and when you
select file option you'll get back to
home and if you select insert option
you'll have another different ribbon
with different groups etc etc so every
particular tool has different ribbons in
them and remember the extra options that
we discussed when you press over this
Arrow key this is it so when you press
the arrow key you'll have few more
settings which cannot be fit in this
particular section of groups so you can
have some variety of options over here
of changing the font changing some
effects to the text font size and font
style etc etc apart from this we have
also discussed about the cells in every
sheet so this particular cell has an
address so you can see the address over
here which is B3 so B happens to be the
column name and three happens to be the
row name now we also had a discussion
about the sheet tracker right now we
just have one sheet if you want multiple
sheets you can just feel free to select
on the plus option which will always
create you some extra sheets and you can
navigate through sheets just by pressing
on the sheet
name and when you get back to the bottom
right corner you have an option of
increasing and decreasing the cell size
or the sheet size now let's keep it
default with 100% now these are the few
fundamentals that you need to keep in
mind before getting started with
Microsoft Excel now that we know the
fundamentals of Microsoft Excel let's
get started with a practical session
which is about the employees details in
a company now let's select this
particular cell and let's type in
employe
details
yeah we have the cell now an employee
details table will have the information
related to employees so the information
will be about name it will be about
employee
number it will be the
designation and maybe
salary
and maybe PL group as
well and uh let's take another one which
is phone
number
yeah so so far so good and uh you can
see that we have some problem with this
particular column the designation the
name uh the the name of the designation
is practically good but is not visible
so when you uh when you're not on that
particular cell you can see that the
name is incomplete over here so you can
always fix that you can just you know
manually change the size of the row or
cell or you can also feel free to you
know double click on that cell which
will automatically you know set the size
of that particular cell and same goes to
the blood group just let's try to double
click on that and same goes to phone
number
great so you can see that the employ
employes details are just confined to
the first two cells it's supposed to be
somewhere in the middle right so no
problem we can do that as well we can
select all the cells and we have an
option of merging
them you can just select this one which
will help you with merging and centering
that particular data to the center part
so that's how we do it now let's get
started by adding the names of the
employees uh let's add the names Joe
John uh Mary
Mark
Susan and
then
Jennifer let's type in
Mike let's type in
them
Chef
Jeffrey yeah we have a couple of
employees now let's type in the employee
numbers
yeah we have the employee numbers now
let's type in the designation okay let's
choose U Joe to be the CEO of the
company and John as the software
developer and Mar as tester
Mark and
fance Susan also in
finance and Jennifer in
testing and Mike in uh
marketing
same goes for
T and again Jeffrey into software
development and
uh Morgan into testing
again
now let's click on C so that it gets you
know resized according to the length of
the text now it's done so let's get into
salary uh
$10,000 and
$115,000
and
$119,000 let's increase the salary of a
CEO so let's keep it $1
lakh and finance again
20,000 so yeah the salaries are
allocated again the blood
group
yeah we have the blood groups now let's
type in the mobile
numbers
yeah now we have typed in some random
mobile numbers as well so uh yeah this
is how you can add in some data into
your table and now let us imagine that
forgot to add or remove a column so
let's imagine that we wanted to add a
serial number as well but somehow we
forgot to add it now you can always add
a new row or column for example here we
wanted to add a new column so we just
have to right click on a select the
insert option here we have a new row now
now let's type in serial
number and let's type
one now can you see the small box option
over here if you just drag it you can
you know copy paste all those over here
and now let's right
click and fill series now we have the
employee number starting from 1 to 10
that's how you do it and apart from this
you you can also uh you know change the
font of the entire row you can change
the font to say uh aroni and you can
always also change the font and same
goes to the employee table you can
select it bold it and you can also
increase the size and again select a
color for the text maybe a different
color green would be
better and uh you can also select the
entire cells and align them to the
center looks more good and you can
select or double click the row names so
you'll have the proper spacing between
all the rows and columns so we have
double click on the column right yeah so
basically that's how you make things
happen now let's save this so I'd like
to go to the save option and
uh
data let me save this in my local
location and just save it's done so
that's how you work on your Excel file
with some basic data and to learn more
don't forget to get subscribed to Simply
loarn Channel and don't forget to hit
that Bell icon to stay updated so you
are the first person to get an update on
any technology not just Excel now we are
on the Microsoft Excel and this
particular spreadsheet is related to
employee
details yeah now the screen is visible a
bit better now let us imagine that this
is our confidential data and you want to
edit only two columns that is the
designation column and phone number
column now let us imagine that the
company has finished one annual year and
now there are some promotions happening
in the company and let us also imagine
that the phone numbers of the employees
provided by the company have undergone
some changes so now the minor edits that
you want to make are related to the
designation column and phone number
column now you can see that all the
columns that is the blood group new
salary salary hike current salary and
name of the employee serial number
employee number everything is editable
so in such kind of scenarios when you
pass on this data there might be a
possibility where your colleague or
subordinate might end up making some
mistakes right so you want to avoid that
so you can do that by locking the cells
now let us rename this
sheet now the sheet has been renamed
successfully so now you can log the
cells by the following
process so in this process you have two
major steps first one is to log the
cells and the next one is to protect the
cells by a password now when you select
all the cells in this particular sheet
you can just click on this edge here and
you have all the cells selected and now
right click somewhere on the sheet and
you can see an option called format
sales so in this particular option you
have some options provided which is
number alignment font and you want to go
into the protection part so you can see
by default Excel
keeps all the cells locked now we want
the phone number and designation to be
unlocked okay so let's cancel it for now
and get back to the sheet and select the
columns D and I and now let's right
click and go into format sales and in
the protection option make sure that you
uncheck the logged icon now select okay
and
now okay so you cannot include the
merged cell fine we have a cell here
which is merged okay let's remove
that okay now again select the entire
column right click get into format cells
and uncheck the lock option select
okay now we have finished the first part
that is locking all the cells which you
don't want to get edit and unlocking the
cells where you want to make some edits
now the second stage is protecting the
sheet now right click on the sheet name
and you can see an option called protect
sheet click that and now here you can
see select locked Cs and also select
unlocked CS so let us provide a password
here so let us use some simple password
so that we don't forget that so I'll be
selecting 1 2 3 and now select
okay re-enter the password to proceed
now let us type 1 2 3 again now select
okay and now the sheet is
protected now we have successfully
locked and protected all the cells in
Excel now let us verify that the cells
you wanted to protect are really
protected and locked or not so we have
unlocked phone number and designation
and everything else is lock now let me
try and edit the blood group so when I
double click or try to edit this
particular sheet then I'll be receiving
a warning from Excel it says the cell or
chart you're trying to change is on a
protected sheet to make a change
unprotect the sheet you might be
requested to enter a
password so it says that this particular
cell is locked and you cannot edit it
now let us try to edit the phone numbers
which we kept as unlocked so you can see
I can really edit the unlocked cell here
now let me try to change this phone
number let me enter some random phone
number so you can see the cell is
editable now let us go through the
designation column and try to edit this
particular column now since I said that
there's a promotion happening in the
company so the deputy CEO is now the
current CEO of the company and software
developer happens to become the senior
software developer and the tester as
well let us imagine the that he will
become the
senior and so on okay so this proves
that this particular sheet is editable
not the entire sheet but only the cells
that we kept in the unlock
mode
okay now this is how you lock and
protect your Sals in
Excel so to understand the page setup in
msxl we will go through a demo inventory
in Excel where we'll be considering some
restaurant data now without any delay
let's get started with the Practical
demo now we are on the Excel sheet and
this is the data I was talking about the
restaurant data where we have the First
Column that is Rank and next we have the
restaurant name followed by that we have
the sales happening through that
Resturant and then we have the segment
category that is what kind of service
does that particular restaurant offers
now this is the list what we made and uh
what if we wanted to represent this data
in the form of a printed paper right so
I guess you can see all the columns and
rows here so you can see that we have
almost like 250 rows so there is no
chance or there is no way to print all
those 250 rows in one page of course it
is practically possible but when you try
to read the content it'll be so tough to
read Because all the row will be clued
together so closely so that you cannot
read it so uh you need to print them
Page by page so and you need to also
take care of the data is aligned
properly according to the page size
everything and even you need to take
care of the margins of your page right
so that's what P set up basically means
so we had a detailed overview of our
data and what actually we're trying to
make now let us see how page setup is
possible in msxl so to go to the page
setup menu or go to the page setup
options we have three methods let's
start with the simplest method so the
simplest method is by just clicking on
file and go to print
option and you'll see all the page setup
options right over here and you can also
go to print menu by pressing in a
shortcut method that is controll p so
you'll directly end up on the page setup
options now let's look at the second
method so the second method is you can
see the toolbar over here right which
has file home insert draw page layout
formulas data review View and help so
the second method we can use page layout
option from the toolbar and you can see
when you click on the page option from
the toolbar you have a new ribbon over
here so this ribbon is all about page
setup options so it will offer you
margins it will offer you orientation
size print area brakes background print
tiles etc etc right so all these options
or menus in this ribbon belong to page
setup now let us look at the third
method so the third method is something
similar you have have view option on the
toolbar so just select View and you can
see we have few page setup options over
here as well the normal page break page
layout custom views and we have grid
lines formula bar heading zoom in zoom
out select to zoom free certain paines
right so all these are also the page
setup options so we have the three
methods to enter the page setup options
now we are familiar with those now let's
get started with the Practical modee on
page setup for that let me use the
simplest method that is holding the
control key and pressing P which
navigates me to the print
option now we have various set of
options here we have no scaling normal
margins letter portrait orientation
collated print active sheets and note
one for Windows you can see this option
is the printers option for example if
you're connected to a printer
which is the hardware printer then your
msxl will show the printer's name here
so other than printer you can also make
some other arrangements where you can
just directly print your complete data
in the form of PDF and then you can
export your PDF to your recipent that's
also possible okay now let's get started
with the first option that is print
active pages okay to understand this
better we need to create a new sheet not
a problem so you can see that we just
have one sheet over
here so let us kind of select all the
items and create a new sheet and try to
paste it over here or let's try to paste
it over
here okay now let's try to extend
this yeah this should be fine now let's
rename this sheet sheet
uh or let's rename it as
Resturant sheet
to for our reference now let us get back
to the print sheet option so I'll use
the shortest method that is holding the
control key and press P now you can see
that here we have six pages in total
from the active sheets so the current
active sheet is the top 250 sheet so so
this particular sheet is the current
active sheet so if we print the entire
data in this particular sheet then we
will end up printing six pages now let
us select the other option where you
have to print the entire workbook right
so now you can see that there's a change
in the number that is 12 pages so what
is a workbook so basically workbook is
the collection of entire sheets in your
Excel homepage so in this particular
Excel homepage you have the first sheet
that that is top 250 and the second
sheet that is the restaurant sheet two
right so the combination of these two
sheets make up a
workbook so when you select the entire
workbook option you'll have 12 pages so
that's how we use this setting where you
select the active sheets the entire
workbook and there is another option
where you can only print a selected item
so if you want to do this then let's get
back here now what if your customer or
what if your client wanted the top 10
restaurants only so you can select the
top 10
restaurants by doing
this now you have the top 10 restaurants
let's go to
print so you can see Excel has
automatically selected the selection
only print the selected content only so
so you can see we have only the top 10
restaurants or top 11 restaurants that
we have selected in our sheet and it is
ready to get printed so this is how we
use the first option now let's get back
let's not select that and let's make the
pages normal now get back to the print
option again now you can see the next
option that is
cated right so in colet you have
different different options that is 1 2
3 1 2 3 and 1 2 3 and the next one which
is uncollated 1 1 1 222 333 so why are
these numbers present here and what does
CED mean anyway so this is your question
right now the answer for this question
will be a little similar to your
examination Hall okay let us imagine
that you are an examination Hall and you
are the invigilator and you have 10
students in your room so you wanted to
Pro provide question papers to all the
10 students okay so you have your
question paper distributed into three
sheets that is you have marked questions
and your questions are fit into three
papers right in this scenario we have
250 rows and all the data is split into
six sheets that is sheet one or page one
page two page three page four right now
if we wanted to print 10 copies then the
arrangement of paper first will be page
1 page 2 page three page 4 page 5 page
six in continuous order right that is
cleed if you wanted 10 copies of
different different ways where you
wanted to print the first sheet first
then you wanted to print the second
sheet second and the third sheet third
that is you'll have 10 copies of first
page 10 copies of second page 10 copies
of third page and so on that particular
approach is called un cated approach and
if you're printing the pages in
continuous order for 10 times then that
particular approach is called as coated
approach so this is what we had to learn
about collet and uncol now let's get
back to the third option now let's press
again print now we have our data over
here there's something
wrong select all the elements control P
yeah now we have our data back
now we have the third option that is the
portrait
orientation okay so when we click that
we have two options that is portrait and
landscape so you might be having a good
idea like when you try to click a
picture in your phone we have two modes
as well that is portrait mode and the
landscape mode so when you click on the
portrait mode this is how your data will
be looking now to understand the
difference let's click the landscape
mode so when you click the landscape
mode this is how your data
representation will change you'll have a
wider page to print so this is why we
use the page orientation for now let's
get the page orientation as portrait
orientation and we have now the fourth
option so what is the fourth option we
have various sets of options in here
that is letter and A4 size there are
also some more page options over here
where you can select the page types you
want to
print
so basically you'll be having few more
options that is A4 A5 A3 Etc but here we
just have two that is A4 and letter so
basically you'll get those options and
followed by that next we have margins so
here you can see we don't have any
margins for our data okay so now we can
add some margins by setting up this one
as an option like last custom setting or
you can also choose
normal wide narrow right so your page
will be changed according to your margin
size right so this is how you can change
the margins now let's keep it as default
let's set the normal
one now we have the next option that is
scaling
option so so here you can see we are
trying to fit the page so when you're
trying to print these sheets using no
scaling then the actual size of the page
will be printed now you can also modify
that you can fit and print these sizes
so you can remember the first option
that I said of printing all the 250 rows
in one single sheet this is how you can
fit it so fit the sheet on one page
where you can see all the 250 rows are
fit into one page but the dat data is
not readable so but we don't want this
type of an approach right so let's keep
it as the default one which is no
scaling so these are the variety of
options in print now if you wanted to
print the all the six pages into the PDF
format and mail it to your client you
can also do that I think I have
explained it in the first place so you
can see we can do it by just selecting
this option where you can print all the
six pages and into PDF form and then you
can mail them to your
client and you can also select the
number of copies you want you can
increase the copies to two three and any
number of uh copies you want for now
I'll keep it as one
[Music]
copy now let's print
this
now let us select
the
location rename it and
publish now let's get back to documents
and see if the page is printed or
not here you go here we have the restant
data in the form of
PDF so we have our entire six pages of
data in the PDF
format now we are back on the homepage
now we had some limited functions in the
print function over here we had tried to
export the data so you can also export
the data or try to print it from the
print option over here you can just
select that as well you
can
pdf2 yes the pages are printed
now there you go we have the restaurant
2 PDF
[Music]
data so that's how you can print all
your data you can either
choose the export option or you can
either choose print option now when you
see into the print option we have
limited number of page setup options
over here now let's check out what we
missed so we are in the page layout here
so we had gone through the margins we
had set all the margins and then we have
also gone through the portrait and
landscape now you can see this size when
we were in the print menu option we had
only A4 and letter but here you can see
there are a wide variety of options that
is other than letter we have tabloid
legal statement executive
A3 right we have A5 and many more other
options and if you want some more paper
options you can go to more and you can
always select a few more options that's
how you do it and yeah we didn't had the
break option so remember when we had
been through the print option we did not
have the break option there let's select
this to noral A4 so you cannot see the
break option over here right so here we
have the break option so what does break
option does right you can actually break
the page uh remember we spoke about the
top 10 things or the top 10 rows you can
always do that so you can just keep the
top 10 restaurants in your first page
and then break the remaining and to set
page breaks you can select the cell now
I need the top 10 so I'll select this
particular cell which is in the 11th
position and now I'll try to implement
the page break insert a page break and
now you can see on my sheet there is a
thin line which is separating the two
pages that's how you can see the
indication of page break implemented
onto your page now how do you see it you
can see it by selecting control P where
you can see the first top 10 restaurants
being printed on your sheet so there you
go we have the first top 10 restaurants
printed on our sheets so that's how you
use the page
break now let's try to eliminate all the
page breaks so you can select braks and
reset all page breakes so the page break
has been
eliminated now you can always choose a
background for your data as well you
just uh if you want you can add a
picture to your background I think
that's not available for
now okay you can work offline as well
let us select this
one so you can see that we have added a
background to our
data we can select all the text files
and then we can change the color so that
the text becomes a little visible yeah
that's how you do it now if you don't
want the image to be added on your file
you can also remove that delete page
background and there you go all the
images are gone now the next important
part that is the print
titles now why do we need print titles
for that let's try to print this so now
you can see the first page in the first
page we have the title rank restaurant
sales segment category but if you go to
the second page you don't have that
title right you don't have the title
rank name of the restaurant sales and
their service category so if we want
that then we need to add titles now for
that let's select the print titles
option now let's select the rows to
repeat on top now for that we need the
first row select the first row and this
particular row will be repeating into
all the pages now let's try to print it
so yeah now you can see the titles are
being added to all the sheets sheets you
can see the page two page three page
four page five and page six so you can
see the titles added to all the sheets
so that's how use the print titles
option so now we are on the Excel sheet
and you can see that in this particular
Excel sheet we have some student details
we have the serial numbers names role
numbers class blood group and some
subjects like math science computer
statistics social GK and the final marks
obtain percentage and total marks
right so let us imagine that uh a
company has come for an interview so all
these students are going to attend an
interview and uh the minimum percentage
to attend the interview will be like
75% so you can see that we have 75 here
and all the students have got above 75
except for the one student which is Mike
right so for Mike to attend the
interview he needs 75 percentage or
above so uh he can make some
modifications in one of these subjects
right so there is always an exam after
the exam called as Improvement exam so
if you can like to score some extra
marks in the subjects which you have
scored less so that you can make up to
the percentage what you're expecting you
can do that so here in this particular
sheet uh Mike has six subjects right and
in six subjects you can see he has
scored 76 91 45 71 94 and 62 so out of
these he have scored Less in one subject
compared to all the subjects one subject
is really low that is computers so what
if he can give an improvement exam and
increase his percentage to 75 right so
that can be done so we can do some root
Force methods like we can change the
marks like 55 and then check this
particular one so it's getting 74 right
so using the brute force method will be
a little bit l lengthy so you can do
this because it is just a small uh table
which has least number of data and you
just have one single cell to modify so
that can be done in small tables but
what if you had some table with hundreds
of rows or thousands of rows that will
be timeconsuming right so for that we
have some inbuilt functionality in Excel
that is called goalseek in Excel so for
now let's eliminate the marks
here
so we have eliminated the marks and the
upgraded percentage is 65 now we need
the target as
75 okay so let's uh write it
as Mike's Target right we need mic so
Mike's new Target
as
[Music]
okay now to make sure that we need a
Mark here which can get mic to 75
percentage we will use the data
operation so here on the toolbar which
has file home insert Etc we have one
other option called as data so when you
click on data from toolbar you'll have
this ribbon and in this ribbon we have
various options so when you come into
forecast group
we have an option called wtif analysis
when you click on wtif analysis you'll
have a set of options out of which we
have goal seek now for goal seek we need
to select a table cell that is this
particular table cell that is
M9 so we need the value 75 here right so
what is the cell that you need to change
here for that you need to select this
one and select this particular cell here
right and now you can select okay
now you can see that Excel has
automatically run all the permutations
and combinations and has come up with a
number so that the overall percentage of
mic will be 75% right so the expected
marks that mik should be getting in his
computer's Improvement exam should be
equal to 56 or greater than 56 to get
the final Target as 75 so that he can
attend the company's interview so this
is how we use goal set or goal seek in
Excel so here you can see columns and
rows so especially the fourth row and
the column C right so uh currently we
have data on our uh spreadsheet and it
is exceeding the number of rows
currently visible on our screen right so
when you scroll down you can see that
the header or the headers of all the
columns are getting vanished or scrolled
up along with the data right and you
might want to keep that so that you'll
have reference to every single aspect of
or every single cell data you're
referring to right so for that reason
you might want to freeze this and also
you might have a doubt what if uh even
even I had this data in the column
section right and what if I had to
freeze that and you know when when you
scroll this and keep that data uh set on
the column as it is right so we can also
do that let's look at both of them so
there is a simple process to do that all
you have to do is select the cell or for
which you want to uh you know set the or
freeze the column adjacent to it or the
row adjacent to it right so currently
you want to let me expand it so
currently I want to freeze this
particular row right and this particular
column so the cell I would be selecting
is the first cell here that is
D5 right so when I select this
particular cell I can be able to freeze
this particular row and this particular
column so now you need to navigate to
the tool bar and then select the view
menu and inside view option you can see
there is an option of freeze pains right
so click on the drop down so you can see
three different options as we discussed
earlier we can either choose to freeze
an entire row that is the second option
or you can freeze the entire column that
is the third option or you can freeze
both that is the first option right
freezing rows and columns so let's
select this one and see if our rows and
columns are frozen or not right so now
let's scroll down and you can see our
row is successfully Frozen there right
and similarly scroll towards right and
you can see our column has been
successfully Frozen right so this is how
you freeze rows and columns or you can
freeze pains in Excel now let's quickly
get onto the Practical mode where we
will have some data sets over which we
will be trying to apply the charts now
there are various types of charts in
table and those are the pie chart the
column chart the bar chart column versus
line pavier chart and Spark line charts
so we will discuss one after the other
first let us discuss about the P chart
so as you can see we have a small data
set on my screen which I have personally
created and uh this deals with the
companies and this deals with the shares
of the automobile industry so now for
this let's create a pie
chart select all the data and then get
into the toolbar and inside the toolbar
you can see various options and inside
that we're going to use the insert
option and when you select the insert
option you will have a ribbon here and
inside the ribbon you can see groups
tables illustrations addin and here you
go these are the charts so now we needed
a pie chart so select on that icon and
you have various types of pie charts you
have two dimensional pie charts three
dimensional pie charts donut type of
charts Etc right so I would like to go
with the three dimensional pie chart as
it looks a little more appealing and
easy to understand and now there you go
this is the title of the chart and these
are the legends of the chart and this is
the chart area and these are the value
vales now we can uh you know kind of add
the data labels as well so you can just
have to press the plus icon over here
and you'll have the options you can add
the data labels which will give you a
lot more interesting
values and uh you can also turn this
around as you can see we on double
clicking any part of the pie chart
you'll get this option which is called
as format data point and uh let's
imagine that you wanted to show the
information related to this particular
one which is Volvo which has the biggest
share so this is in front right now now
what if you wanted to show the
information related to data which is
over here right for that you can select
this particular Arrow key and you can
just twist it and there you go it is
coming in front this will be uh a great
way of presenting your data to your
clients
right yeah and there is another option
where you can
directly explode this like you can pick
it out you can see this right Point
explosion where you can split it out and
you can show that especially like you
can highlight it and show it so that's
the you know a great way of presenting
your data so that's how you can work
with pie charts in Excel now let's
quickly move to the next one that is the
column chart and in the column chart we
have the data related to some company
and uh the profits of that company based
on on a year so you can see that the
year has started from 2008 and it has
gone until
2021 and these are the profits of that
company year after year so since we are
dealing with column chart I'll tell you
the simplest way to create a column
chart there is a shortcut key for that
which is alt F1 and there you go you
have the chart right on your
screen now you can uh expand the chart
just by dragging it like that and you
can see that there is some problem with
this chart that is we have numbers here
instead of es right you can see that the
First Column is the es which is 2008
2021 but here you can see we have 1 12 3
4 which is not proper right so to change
the axis that is you can see the axis
which is 1 2 3 4 from 1 2 3 4 to the
years 2008 2009 2010 11 Etc you just
have to make one change here and also
you can see I have pressed the plus icon
over here which will open the option
where you can include the access titles
if you have and data labels everything
right so for now I think I'll keep it as
it is so you can include the data table
as well as it is here and you can
include that in the chart there are
various options that Excel provides you
so now let's uh focus on changing the
axess from 1 to 34 to the ears for that
you need to select the chart design and
inside the chart design you have an
option called select data press that and
here you have various set of options you
can see profits you can see ears now
we'll select ears and we will remove
that and now you can see the edit option
here right select that and now it will
ask you which column to be selected for
the access range for that let's select
this and now let's select the the ears
here and press okay and there you go
again press okay so there you go you
have the ears over here instead of the
numbers which you had in the first place
so that's how you create the column
chart and we have the next type of chart
which is really simple now you know you
kind of change this chart directly into
bar chart there is no big deal in
that so uh for that you just need to
select the change chart type option over
here you're just changing the chart type
and you can get the bar graph over here
column and bar graphs are completely
same to each other only that you can see
these uh bars in the horizontal way
rather than in the vertical way let's do
that let's not create a new thing for
that so uh yeah there you go when you
select the change chart type option you
have various set of chart type options
on the menu bar over here so what we
needed was the bar chart now let's
select that and there you go let's
select okay and you have the bar
chart right and you if you want you can
include the data labels which look a
little bit more interesting you can also
include the data table as
well okay for now I think we have to
expand the chart to get the Clear
View yeah that's how you do
it right now let's move into the next
type of one yeah we dealt with the bar
chart so we'll directly enter into the
column versus line chart so we have
similar kind of data we just had year
and profits in the previous part now we
also have included the expenses right we
needed another column to showcase the
line chart compared to the columns right
so for that I've included a new column
that is expenses as well now just let's
select the
data and let's select the the option alt
F1 to create our
chart right now automatically uh Excel
has provided us the column chart we have
The Columns of expenses we have the
column of profits and we also have ears
now let's change the data as we did
before select uh year and remove it and
then
edit select edit and select the year
that is from here to
2021 select okay and we have the ears
over here now what we needed to do is
change the chart type right select the
change chart type option and since we
wanted to create a column versus line
chart it is a combination whenever you
want one or two types of charts included
in one single chart window then it has a
combo option so here we need need to
select the combo option and inside that
we have various types of combination
charts we have clustered column we have
clustered line on secondary axis we have
clustered stat areas clustered column
and the other one is custom combination
so let's go with the first one that is
clustered line let's select that and
there you go we have the line graph with
the column so that's how we create the
column versus line and if you want you
can include the data labels and you can
include the data table as well yeah okay
I think uh we need to expand the canvas
a little more to get a clear
view
yeah so you have Legends over here you
have the data labels and accesses
everything and chart title you can
always change the chart title so for now
let's uh rename it as profits versus
expenses
yeah that's that's how it
goes done okay I think I made a spelling
mistake
here yeah it's clear now now the next
type of chart we're going to deal with
is the P
chart so uh we have dealt with pie chart
column chart bar chart and column versus
line now P chart is a little bit
different it's like you're going to
create some active chart which responds
to the variations you're making to your
data so to understand that better let's
create a practical chart over here I
select all the
data
okay yeah I have selected the data now
to create a pivot chart let let's
select the insert option from the
toolbar and inside the ribbon we have
charts group and inside that we have P
chart now let's select the P chart
option and there you go now it's asking
for range and we have selected the range
over there and uh we are not going to
create a new worksheet for the entire
chart we are going to create the uh
chart inside the existing worksheet
itself so for that let's select the
uh area where we want to select the uh
chart to be present now for that let's
select this and uh yeah select
okay okay there is some
error let's cancel this and try
again let's select the
data and prev chart
again we have selected the r
range
yeah that's how you select the range and
now select the position where you want
to create it existing worksheet we have
selected that and press okay yeah that's
that's the way we've got our P chart
over here and you can see our P chart is
completely blanked right now it will
respond to the changes you make to your
previous chat for now we have uh serial
numbers and U these are the names of the
guys who
have okay so these are the names of the
guys you who have some dealerships for
various car Mak such as Ford Ferrari
Honda Kia Alpha Romeo BMW etc etc so uh
we're going to change or we're going to
see um you know we're going to make some
charts of the persons who owns the cars
or the car brands or dealerships in
various regions so we're going to work
on that now let's drag in the
name and uh let's drag
region and
cards and the
units yep so we have our uh chart over
here called chart which has the
different different names and the
dealerships and some of cars over there
right so you can see that we can also
change some values over here what if we
wanted to know only uh the details
regarding Jennifer you can do that you
can unselect everything and you can just
select Jennifer and press okay now
you'll have the details of only Jennifer
of having the car brands so we have the
regions as well so Jennifer owns
dealerships in two different regions
that is South and West and uh the sum of
units and count of cars as well so
that's how the PV charts are used in
real
time and now let's select sales and drag
the sales as
well yeah it's been dragg and you have
the sales of U
Jennifer the details of her sales and
let's move the chart a little bit and
you have the plus icon where you can
include the detail laes for a better
information yeah so that's how you use
the P charts so we are on the last type
of charts which is the spark line chart
Now to create a spark line chart we need
to get into the insert option and ins
that we have the ribbon and inside the
ribbon we have the group that is spark
lines
now to generate a spark line chart we
need to select this particular column
and then select the type of spark line
you want to create for now let's create
the column type of spark line chart yep
we have to Club these cells together
first we forgot that because we're going
to insert the spark line chart right
above here now for that let's merge the
cells
[Music]
yeah so uh we wanted to create
the spark line chart of column type and
now it's asking for the location where
we want to create the spark line chart
so this is the location now let's select
okay and there you go we have the spark
line chart right over here now you can
see that we have a negative Point here
so if you want you can change that from
negative to positive and it will
automatically update that and if you
want to add the access to this
particular chart you can select the
options spark line and and there you go
you have certain options like High Point
low point and if you wanted to add some
margins you can also do
that add data type access and there you
go you have the
access show access yeah you have the
access now and you can have the high
point and low point for that as well
which is the you know the biggest change
and the small smallest change in this
particular segment that is f Furniture
yeah Furniture had the highest sales in
January and uh Home Appliance had the
lowest sale and you can also change the
color and uh let's type of change the
color again yeah we have a different
color over here which resembles a little
bit more better or you can also go with
this one and if you wanted to add the
same to all these tables you can do that
just by dragging it and and you have it
for all the 6
months now if you wanted to add some new
data in this row or you wanted to add a
new complete row then you can do that as
well and change that and bring that
change implemented in these charts as
well now let us try to add a new row
here which includes the miscellaneous we
have that data right over here let's
select
that copy and uh let's paste it over
here so there you go we have the extra
row here so yeah now we have added the
miscellaneous row and right now we have
the spark line chart for only four
columns or four rows that is Furniture
technology home appliances and office
needs and miscellaneous is missing now
to add that as well let's select spark
line and inside spark line just select
edit Group location and data and now
let's select the entire
data and now select
okay there's something wrong
again spot line added
data select
range this should be helping yeah there
you go we have all the fire rows now
including Furniture technology home
appliances office needs and
miscellaneous as we speak you might
wonder what it takes to become an expert
data analyst if you are an aspiring data
analyst with at least one year of domain
experience and looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learns
postgraduate program in data analysis
from Pur University in collaboration
with IBM should be your right choice for
more details on this course head
straight to homepage and type in
postgraduate program and data analysis
or simply click on the link in the
description box below with that in mind
over to our training experts so
conditional formatting is a method to
visualize your worksheet we already have
the charts in Excel to visualize our
Excel sheets in graphical form but what
if you had to see or visualize the data
in your worksheet as it is so that is
where the condition formatting comes
handy now let's get back to the
Microsoft Excel and try try to implement
some conditional formatting now we are
on the Excel worksheet this particular
data set is based on a store now we have
various columns in this particular data
set we have row ID order ID customer
name Etc and finally we have quantity
discount and profits now let's go to
profits uh let us imagine that we have
provided this particular store with a
target of minimum 15% profits now let us
find out the stores that have hit the
15% Target and the ones which did not so
for that let us select the entire column
now you can find the conditional
formatting option in the home toolbar
and in that ribbon the ribbon with
Styles has the conditional formatting
option click on that and you have
various options over here highlighting
the cells top bottom rules data bar data
scales and icons so datab bar are
actually the bar graphs which highlight
themselves on on each and every cell if
you implement them and these are the
color scales if you want to implement
some colors you can go through that and
if you want to represent your sales with
icons you can also do that for now let's
highlight the sales so select that and
inside this select the greater than
option and here you can provide the
percentage that is
15% and the sales or the stores which
hit the target should be highlighted
with green color and select okay and
there you go you have your stores that
hit the 15% Target and the ones which
did not hit the 15% Target now if we
want to highlight the ones which did not
hit the 15% Target you can highlight
them with the color
red
so conditional formatting highlight the
Cs less than
15% with color red and text dark and
there you go it's done now let us
consider another example so this
particular example is based on train
data set and here we have the passenger
ID survived passenger class name Etc now
we have a train accident incident over
here now one is indicated that they are
alive and zero is indicated that they
are not alive now let us use this column
and conditional formatting highlight the
cells containing the text as one with
color
green uh
okay
and highlight the
cells that contain text zero as red that
indicates they are not
alive and let us select the
icons now we have the icons over here
the X indicates that they're not alive
and the Green Tech Mark indicates that
they're alive now that is how you use
conditional formatting in Excel
now here on my spreadsheet you can see
some data so this particular data has
some color markings so we have used
color codes to Mark the designations of
all the employees with different colors
so for example blue for manager purple
for senior and so on right now our duty
is to count the total number of
employees present in a company based on
the color code this can be done using
filters but let's try with color codes
now we don't have a readily available
function in Excel to count cells based
on their colors but we can make use of
macro now to make use of macro you might
want to enable the developer options so
by default these will be disabled in
Excel to enable them right click on the
toolbar and you can see this particular
option click on the customize ribbon
option and you will be provided with
various set of options now on the right
side you can see developer options so
make sure the checkbox is clicked to
enable developer options and press on
okay to completely enable developer
window right now when you click on
developer options you can see various
options here visual Basics macro Etc now
click on the macro to create a macro now
just give a name to the macro function
so I'll give simply
Lo and press on create to create that
particular macro function so we have
already created a macro that is Count
colored cells which we will be using in
our current spreadsheet for counting the
colored cells now let us erase the newly
created function now getting back to the
original code so how does this
particular count colored cells works so
let us understand the function first
then we will try to make use of it in
the spreadsheet so the function name is
Count colored cells as you can see and
this particular function will have two
parameters current cell and spreadsheet
area so the current cell will be the
cell address where the color you want to
count is present and then the
spreadsheet area so what is the range of
cells where you want to locate that
particular color and count the number of
repetition that is the spreadsheet area
and then comes the variables used
colored cell range color code and color
cell count so the colored cell which
particular cell is having that
particular color and what color code is
involved in that colored cell and
colored cell count so what is the total
count what is the total number of
colored cells you have in that
particular range that is colored cell
count now let us consider color code is
equals to current cell interior color
that is current cell do interior do
color so this is the function which will
identify the interior color of a
selected cell let us imagine that
initially color code is equals to the
current cell's color code okay now we
will have the for Loop and that for Loop
will include colored cell which is the
current cell in the spreadsheet area and
if the colored cell the currently
selected colored cell do interior dot
color is equals to the color code that
we have selected then colored cell count
the variable which is used to count the
number of colored cells is equals to +
one initially by default it will be zero
in case if this particular if condition
is true that is the current cell color
and the color code given is equals to
same then the value of colored cell will
increase by one and this particular if
Loop will run as many number of times
the condition is true so let us imagine
that the condition will remain true for
five times then we have obtained five
similarly colored cells in the given
range of cells in a spreadsheet and once
the condition fails then the latest
value present in color cell count
variable will be displayed which will be
a final result so this is how the macro
fun function works now let's close the
macro window and get back to our
spreadsheet now let us try to make use
of the macro function that we just
created so that is equals to count
colored cells press tab to select the
macro function and the first one is the
current cell so this is the current cell
where the current color is being
provided comma the cell range so our
cell range will be from C2 to
c31 right so this is the range where we
we want to count the similarly colored
cells that is sky blue colored cells
close the function and press enter now
you can see the function has identified
six reputations of sky blue color in
this particular range of cells now you
can drag the same formula across all the
cells and it will be providing the
results of the same so six senior colors
that is pink or purple color then two
reputations of this particular color two
reputations of trainy color five for
dark blue and six for green right so
this is how the macro function works and
the key point to remember here is this
particular macro will work only for
manually colored cells so there are
situations where we have used
conditional formatting to color a single
cell let is imagine that we have used
conditional formatting to recognize the
employees with salary above 30,000 as
green color and if we try to use that
particular green color to be counted by
the color count cells function no it
will not happen it will not consider
that color as a feedback or an input now
in future we will also try to design a
macro which can recognize the colors
made by conditional formatting as well
but this particular function will be
exclusively used for manually colored
cells
only so what is data validation in Excel
so it is a feature by Microsoft Excel
where it can restrict data entry into
certain cells by using data validation
and it will prompt the users to enter
valid data in the cells based on the
rules and restrictions provided by the
creator of that particular sheet now
this would be a little confusing to
understand so to understand it in a much
better way let's get back to the
practical way where we will start
entering some data validation rules to
our Excel sheet and try to enter data
into it now we are on the Microsoft
Excel and this particular sheet is based
on employee ID employee name employee
Department employee salary fiscal year
and work timings of the
employees now we will be applying some
data validation rules to each and every
column and try to enter data based on
the rules we have entered now for the
first one which is the employee ID we'll
enter rules based on the employ ID
number so to apply the data validation
you need to go into the data tab on the
toolbar and inside the ribbon you can
see data tools group and in the data
tools group you have the option of data
validation now select the entire column
go to the data tools group select data
validation option and you will have this
particular popup menu and here you can
see different types of options so since
we are entering employee ID it would be
a whole number so let us select whole
number option and now here you can see
the option of between not equal to equal
to not between greater than less than
Etc so let us
between and let us assume that your
employee ID has five numbers and uh it
should be between 10,000 to
11,000 so let us provide
10,000 and
11,000 now select okay and now the new
rule has been
applied
so now the minimum value of each and
every employee ID should be equal to or
more than 10,000 and less than 11,000
and it should have five digits now let's
try to enter a wrong employee ID that is
just one there you go you can see that
Microsoft Excel is not allowing you to
include a wrong number it says this
value does not match the data validation
restrictions defined for this cell so
now you can press just retry and try to
enter some number which is in between
10,000 to
11,000 now it is
10,901 and this will take the
entry now let is assume that because I'm
the creator of this sheet I know what
should be entered here but what if I
give this sheet to you and you're the
person who's trying to enter the number
and it shows the error and you don't
know what was the error right to avoid
this kind of confusion what you can do
is you can do some uh ways where you can
provide the message to the user so that
can be done by okay let's select the
sheet again and go to the data
validation and here you have the same
settings now here you have another
option saying input message so before
input message let us go to error alert
now
here the error title would be data
entered
is not
valid please enter this is the error
message please
enter
EMP
ID
between
10,000 to
11,000 press okay now when you try to
enter the wrong number it will show that
particular error alert
message see data entered is not valid
please enter employee ID between 10,000
to 11,000 now this is fine but how long
this will be you know what if there is
an option where you just hover over to
this cell and it automatically tells you
to enter the value between 10,000 to
11,000 without having to face the error
yeah even that can be done so you can
select the entire column go to data
validation and here this is the input
message this is where you can do that so
here you can write the message name
valid
data please
enter data
between 10,000 to 11,000 now when you
hover over to any in this particular
column it will automatically show you
this message where you can avoid all the
errors just select okay see when you
select any cell in this particular
column it will automatically tell you
please enter data between 10,000 to
11,000 so here you don't have to face
any errors right now let us try to enter
the valid
data
02 and it will take it as the correct
value and again 1
903 now in case if you try to provide
the wrong number it will show the
error
see so that's how it is now we have
finished the whole number part now let's
get into the employee name where we have
to
provide uh the second type that is text
length now let us imagine that uh in
your company you're trying to provide ID
cards to employees and you know that ID
card is really small and inside that ID
card you need to include the employee
photograph and your company name
employee ID blood group phone number
address everything and also you need to
include the name of the employee so what
if there is an employee with very
lengthy name like 30 characters 40
characters yeah in India it is really
possible that you might have a lengthy
name so what you can do is you can
provide the text length where the text
is limited to like 15 or 20 uh um
characters so you can include that name
in the ID card so you can do that by
allowing the data validation criteria
with text length uh minimum can be
anything so minimum can be one and
maximum here you can provide 15 and
press okay okay minimum will change it
to at least uh
two and yeah let it be one so minimum is
one and maximum is 15 characters and
press okay and uh let us also provide
the input
message
enter character type character
data please enter valid
name and error alert
invalid
data please enter valid
data okay please enter
characters less
than
15 press
okay now let us try to enter a random
name okay uh we'll enter characters more
than 15 here
quy Z I think
uh yeah it's like 1 2 3 4 5
11 okay now this is more than
15 okay I think it's not more than 15
let's try to enter a little bit more
characters yeah now we have entered more
than 15 characters and it is showing
please enter characters less than 15 so
now we can retry and try to enter some
valid name
uh now we have characters less than 50
so it will take as the proper name now
let us try to enter another
name I'm just entering some random
data so another name
maybe
great now the next type of data
validation is also done now let us get
into employee Department employee
department is something really superb so
I'll tell you about it it's actually a
list now let us finish the other ones
first that is employee salary physical
year and work timings after that we'll
learn about uh the list
one now let's come into employee salary
so salary is something where you have to
include decimal points so now let us go
to uh data validation and inside the
values we have already dealt with whole
number uh text
length yeah now we'll uh deal with
employee salary that is decimal now
minimum is okay what is uh minimum can
be
[Music]
1.0 and maximum can
be 1
lakh or let us put that as 10
lakhs press okay okay not not just then
enter
valid
salary okay now let's change it to
minimum is
10,000
so the employee minimum salary will be
10,000 and input enter valid salary
enter
salary
between
10,000 to 10
lakhs let us include a comma here
too now error alert
invalid
salary please
enter
between
10,000 to 10
lakhs press okay now the message and
data validation conditions are applied
to this column now let us try to enter
some invalid data first it will show the
error now we need to enter the valid
data yeah now it is taking the valid
data let us provide
20,000 and this has
35,000 now the next one is fiscally let
us imagine that we wanted to you know
work on the employees for current
working year that is 2020 to
2021 and or you can consider 2021 to
2022 not more than 2021 and not less
than 2021 for that you can provide the
year option as well so for that you need
to select the entire column go to data
validation settings and inside here you
have an option of date so uh let us
provide the date option as between and
start date is
01/01 SL
2021 and end date is
01/01
SL
2022 and input
message let us provide data as
current fiscal
year Current financial
year enter
date between
2021 to
2022 let just copy this and go into
error alert error message will be seen
invalid
dat select okay now the error message
and uh the data input message and the
data validation rule has been applied
for this column so let's try to enter
some date here you can enter uh 02 of
February
2021 it will take as the correct data
now let's try to enter some wrong data
which is apart from 2022 02
02 20 22 it will not take this it will
throw error so that's how it works now
let us try to enter as
2021 and this is March it will take it
now another
data 04 this time and
2021 so that's how your uh date data
validation will work now coming into the
next type of data validation that is
time so we have time here let us imagine
that you are providing some work timings
to your employees that should be from
9:00 a.m. to 5:00 p.m. not more than
that so you want to keep your work life
balanced for all your employees so you
just want them to work between 9 to 5
and that should be fine and anything
apart from that time should be invalid
so you can do that by selecting uh time
option between it should be in between
and the start time will be
09 0 0 and this should
be
uh
17 that is 5:00 p.m. in the evening and
input
message please
enter time
between 9
a.m.
to
okay 5
P.M
this should be the input
message now error
alert inv valid
time error message okay
now okay work timings now this should be
okay we can do this as two columns
actually let us
cancel let us copy this and paste it
here you can do it as
login login timing and this should be
okay this should be a log
out so this should
be okay so this will be considered as
login and log out times now let us
provide the login time this should be
the right time and uh let's try to
provide wrong timings 08 now it will not
take it it will throw as error so it's
working fine let us provide 10 now let
us provide the log out time it should be
below 5:00 p.m. so let us provide five
it will take
it
okay let's try to provide something just
1 minute less than
five that is
59 okay there is some problem in this
let's check
it
okay it is taking uh three that is
including
seconds okay let's provide seconds as
well 05 0 0 0
0 okay still there is some problem
okay we have entered four we should we
are supposed to enter 24hour timing
right
14 okay uh it should be 17 I think this
will work yeah now we are following
24hour timing here so let's provide
another timing that is
16 30 0 0 this will be valid and
1530 yes this is also valid now we have
finished almost all types of uh data
validation things that is we have
finished with any value whole number
decimal date timing test length and the
last one is list so this is where things
get interesting now let's cancel this
now select the employee column now if
you're running a company then definitely
you'll not have only one Department in
it you might have multiple departments
right so let us consider that you have a
software development company so in that
the basic departments will be software
development team and software testing
team so what you can do is you can
provide a list so using that list you
can just uh H over to that cell select
the drop- down menu and inside that you
can select the option so we will try to
work something like that if we have
selected the entire
column selection
okay yeah let us select the entire
column again go to data validation the
selection contains some cells without
data validation settings do you want to
extend data validation to the sales
yes now let us provide the list
option
and
here Source you can provide
as
developer and
tester press okay
okay now input message select
one select
one error
alert
invalid
data select from drop
down
only press okay now when you select the
cell you can see small drop- down icon
right so when you press it you will have
developer and tester option so you can
select developer for first one and for
second one you can select uh tester
right okay this is good for uh one or
two options maybe three or even maybe
like five but what if you have more
departments okay let's go to this uh
second sheet where we have the
department data so here we have like 14
departments no 15 departments or 15
employee type names so the first one is
CEO second is developer tester quality
analyst system analyst Finance human
resource so so many options are there so
you cannot keep on typing all of them
right so here it is 15 what if you have
like 20 F like 50 departments right it
will be tough so for this you have
another option so let me select all this
data and copy this from this sheet to
our employee
sheet let us paste it
somewhere
here let's expand
this okay now we have our uh list over
here now let us remove the data
validation from this
column
clear all okay now everything is
cleared let's select okay now let us
erase this data as
well now let us apply the list data
validation again from scratch go to
list now here we can select the
source select this particular
cell and drag it until here and it has
been
loaded now go to input
message data
options select
one from the menu or the
drop-down copy error
alert select only from the drop- down
menu invalid entry yeah now let's select
okay fine now you have the icon here you
have all the provided
options you can scroll down and select
any one out of these you can select
knowledge transfer for the first one and
second one would be system
analyst and the last one would be
Human
Resources now in the list everything is
fine okay this is showing you the menu
options and everything so but what if
you provide this sheet to your new joiny
or new employee in your company and by
mistake he messes up something like
deleting this okay so we have deleted
systems analyst and when you click on
the options here you don't have systems
analyst in that place you have blank
space right so there is a way where all
your um you know data can be messed up
so to avoid this what you can do is you
can actually um save this data in a
different sheet like I did here like
Department data you can hide this sheet
or you can protect this sheet with
password or something so that nobody can
mess this up so now let us get back to
the employe data and select this column
and uh clear everything press okay and
let us also clear this
and this as well and this one too now
let us eliminate the rowes or
sales the
employee
everything okay now we have basically
removed this data from here now let us
try to apply the data validation once
again now here let us select as as
list and
uh here let us provide the option let us
go to next sheet let us select all these
options and press okay okay let's
provide input
message data
options or Department options
that
yeah now let's select
okay now let's hide this sheet now the
sheet has been hidden and you still have
the
options
developer or let us provide
CEO then we have
developer then we
have test what is Excel V
lookup V lookup stands for vertical
lookup V lookup lets you search for
specific information in your spreadsheet
it allows you to search for a particular
value in a column and returns another
value from a different column but of the
same Row V lookup takes advantage of
vertically aligned tables to quickly
find data associated with the value the
user enters now let's look at the syntax
to write a v lookup function so V look
up takes four parameters or arguments
you can see it here there are four
arguments in the v look
function so the first argument is called
the look of value the lookup of value
represents the value that you're
searching for next is the table array
the table array represents two or more
Columns of information the third
argument is called the column index
number now this represents the column
number in the table from which the value
must be returned the First Column is one
the second column is two and so on and
then we have the fourth parameter which
is called the range lookup now this
parameter is optional now range lookup
is used to find an exact match so if you
want to find an exact match you need to
enter false or zero meanwhile if you
want an approximate match you need to
enter true or one if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know
more now let me give you a brief
overview on what's going to be in our
demo so for our demonstration we'll use
a sales data set you can see the data
set on the left using this data set
we'll understand how V looka performs an
exact and approximate match we'll see
how we lookup is case insensitive then
we'll perform a wild card character
search we'll understand how to handle
errors when a match is not found and
finally you will look at two-way lookups
now here is a small example of how vooka
works so we want to find the unit sold
by Morgan using the data set on the left
so here you can see I have the data set
it has some rows and columns so these
are the columns which are order date
region there's a representative column
item units there's unit cost and total
and from this table I want to find the
units that were sold by Morgan if you
look look at the table at the bottom you
can see the representative name Morgan
and Morgan has sold 30 units now I want
to find this value using the vlookup
function so here on the right you can
see I have my lookup value which is
Morgan and this is my vooka formula and
using this formula I'm getting the
result as 30 now let's go to our Excel
workbook and perform all the demos one
by one so this is my Excel workbook that
we are going to use for our demo and and
here is the data set we'll be using now
this is the same data set that you saw a
while ago so this data set has seven
columns you have the order date the
region Representatives name item there's
units unit cost and total which is
basically the total or the amount of
sales that was
generated we are going to use a chunk of
this data set and perform our vlookup
analysis so let's see our first example
example and the problem we have at hand
let me go to the exact match tab all
right so here I'm going to use this
chunk of data which is actually taken
from the original data set so we have
taken the first 11 rows from the data
set you can see from row
two till row 12 is going to be our data
set that we'll use so we have a question
here we want to find the items sold by
Thompson so here Thompson is my lookup
value which means looking at Thompson I
want to find the item that is sold so if
you consider our table here you can see
we have the representatives name
Thompson right here and from the table
you can see Thompson sold pencil and I
want to get this value which is pencil
using my vlookup function so let's go
ahead and write our V look of
function I'll consider this as my look
of value and here under item I'm going
to write my V lookup formula to write
the V lookup formula I'll write first
equal to and I'll write V lookup if I
hit tab it will autoc complete all right
now let's give the parameters so first
is going to be the lookup value which is
nothing but Thompson so I'll just select
this cell which is
j17 comma now it's asking to give the
table array so the table array is the
table from which you want to retrieve a
value one thing to keep in mind is that
the value you are looking for should be
the first column of a table and you can
select the table array till the end of
the data set or till the column which
has the value you want to find so here
I'll select my table array starting from
the representatives column till the end
of the item column which is going to be
my table array then I'll select the
column index number so the column index
number is based on the table array you
have selected in this case my colum
index number is going to be two because
we have selected just two columns and
the value which I'm going to find is in
the second column so I'll give two comma
Now the range lookup I'm going to give
is false because I want to find an exact
match so either you can hit tab or you
can write zero which means false if I
close the bracket and hit
enter it will return me the item that
Thompson had sold which is pencil you
can verify from the table that Thompson
had sold pencil all right now let's try
to change the table array and see what
result are we getting so this time I'll
slightly change the table array so again
we are trying to find the item that
Thompson had sold so I'll write my
formula equal to V lookup I'll hit tab
to autoc complete I'll give my lookup
value as Thompson comma this time I'm
choosing my table array starting from
the representatives column
till the end of the data set which is
till p12 again my column index number is
going to be two because if you consider
this table array the item column is the
second column in the selected table
array so I'm going to write it as two
comma the range lookup I want to give as
false because I want to find the exact
match if I close this and hit enter you
can see it has return returned me the
same result that we saw earlier now
suppose let's say this time I want to
start my table array from the region
column which is this column so I want to
select my table array starting from the
region column now this is going to show
me an error because your table array
should always start from the lookup
value column so if you consider Thompson
as the lookup value my table array
should always start from the
representatives column so so let's just
try this example so I'll write V lookup
my lookup value I'm going to give it as
Thompson comma the table array as I
mentioned earlier I'm going to choose
from the region column and let's say
I'll select till the item column give
another comma and this time my column
index number is going to be three
because since the table array has three
columns and my item column is the last
column so I'm going to give my column
index number is three
comma I want to get the exact match so
I'll give zero if I close the bracket
and hit enter you can see it has given
me an
error okay now let me just show you
another method to use vlookup in Excel
so here on the top you can see there's a
formulas Tab and under formulas tab
under function Library you see we have
an option to select look up and
reference if I click on this and if I
scroll down below you can see there's an
option called V lookup let's choose this
all right now here you can give your
lookup value your table array column
index number and the range lookup under
this function arguments dialogue box so
here I want to select my lookup value as
Thompson my table array is going to be
from the representatives column till
let's say the end of the data set
my column index number is going to be
two I'll write two and range lookup I'll
write as false because I want the exact
match if I hit okay you can see it has
given us the exact same result so this
is one of the other ways to use vlookup
in Excel now let's move to the next
sheet which is regarding approximate
match okay so sometimes you might have
cases where you don't have the lookout
value present in the table in those
cases you can tell V lookup to return an
approximate match now one thing to keep
in mind is that your lookup value column
should always be sorted in ascending
order while trying to get an approximate
match so here we are going to use this
table and my lookup value column which
is going to be the representatives
column is already sorted in ascending
order and let's see the question we have
here so I want to find the items sold
and the unit cost for Matt so my lookup
value is going to be Matt now if you see
this table I don't have the
representatives name mat anywhere in the
table now using an approximate match I
want to find the item and the unit cost
so let's do it so here under item I'll
write my vlookup formula so I'll type
vlookup I'll hit tab to complete it and
this time my look of value is going to
be Matt so I'll select this cell comma
my table array I'll select from the
representatives column till the end of
item column because I want to find the
item value for Matt I'll give a comma my
column index number as per the table
array is going to be two comma my range
lookup this time I'm going to give us
true or one so I'll write one close the
bracket hit enter all right it has
returned
binder was the item sold by Matt now
let's try to figure out why we lookup
returned binder as the
item now let's say you were asked to
insert the name Matt to the
representative column in alphabetical
order so where would you place it
ideally you should Place between KL and
Morgan since this column is already
sorted match should appear before Morgan
and after Kel so in an approximate match
we lookup will consider the previous
highest value in this case the previous
highest value before Matt is ql and
hence we look up returned the
corresponding item purchased by Kel
which is binder now
similarly if you wanted to find the unit
cost for
Matt again V lookup will return the unit
cost of KL which is
125 let's just write out so I'll write
bookup my lookup value is Matt comma my
table array for this time is going to be
from Representatives column till the
unit cost column I'll consider I'll give
a comma Now the column index number as
per the table array is going to be four
I'll give another comma and this time
I'll double click true because I want an
approximate match if I close the bracket
hit enter you can see it has returned me
125 which is actually kl's unit code
cost okay we have another question and
this time I want to find the units sold
by Rob now Rob is going to be my lookup
value if you see the representatives
column we don't have Rob now let's see
what V lookup is going to return as the
item for Rob so I'll write V lookup I'll
give my lookup value as Rob comma my
table array is going to start from the
representatives column I'll select till
here I'll give a comma the column index
number is two I'll give another comma
I'll double click on
true I close the bracket hit enter you
can see V lookup has written me pen now
let's understand why V lookup returned
pen for Rob now if you are asked to
insert the representatives name Rob into
this column so ideally Rob would appear
somewhere between Morgan and sorino
because because since this is sorted in
ascending order Rob is actually greater
than Morgan and is less than Soro so as
you know we look up in an approximate
match Returns the previous highest value
which is Morgan here and the
corresponding item for Morgan is pen and
hence we look up returned pen for Rob
all right now moving to the next
sheet which is another property of V
lookup which tells V lookup always looks
to the right this means that your lookup
value must always be on the left and the
value you are going to find out should
always be to the right of the table now
consider this scenario where your lookup
value is on the left in this case it is
the representatives value and I have
taken svino for an example and we want
to find the order date for svino now if
you consider this table your lookup
value which is svino is actually this
column the representatives column and we
are going to find out the order date so
your representatives name is on the
right of the table and the value we are
going to find out is on the left of the
table now as per the property we look up
only looks to the right so if I use the
vlookup function for this example here
I'll write vlookup I'll give my lookup
value as sorino comma my table array
I'll consider from the order date
because I want the order date
till the representatives column I'll
give a comma and this time my column
index number is actually the first
column if I consider my table array as
the first three columns
selected and my range lookup is going to
be false if I close the bracket hit
enter it returns me an error the reason
is V lookup always looks to the right
and this time the value we were trying
to find out was to the left of the
table now if you consider the opposite
case suppose you have the order date and
you want to find the representatives
name you can do that easily because your
lookup value which is the order date is
on the left and your representatives
column is on the right so let's just try
this I'll write V lookup my lookup value
is going to be sorvino's order date so
I'll select it from the table I'll give
a comma my table array will start from
the G column let's say I'll select the
entire table comma and my column index
number will be three if you consider
these as my table
array comma my range lookup is zero if I
close this hit enter you can see we have
got svino corresponding to the order
date all right now let's move to the
next
tab now this tab says
we lookup returns only the first match
so we have a question at hand the
question is find the units sold by
Jardine if you see this table we have
the representatives name Jardine twice
you see here and if you look down we
have Jardin here as well but the item
sold by jardan at the first instance is
pencil and at the second instance it's
desk now as per the property
V lookup always returns the first match
now ideally when we write the V lookup
function and look for the units sold by
Jardine you will see V lookup will
return 36 instead of three let's just
write
out I'll write the V lookup
function my lookup value is Jardine
comma my table array I'll select from
the representatives column till the end
of units column column I'll give a comma
my column index number based on the
table array is three I'll give another
comma Now I want the exact match so I'll
select zero close the bracket and hit
enter now as you can see it returns me
the first match of Jardine which is 36
so we lookup did not consider the second
match now
similarly if you consider this table we
have have Jones repeated Thrice so you
have Jones here you have Jones here for
the second time and also we have Jones
for the third time and let's say you
want to find the unit cost for Jones so
if I write the vup
function I'll consider my look of value
as Jones comma my table
array I'll select from the
representatives column till the end of
unit cost column I'll give a comma based
on the table array my unit cost column
is at the fourth index so I'll write
four comma the range lookup is zero if I
click on this and hit enter you can see
it here V lookup has returned the first
instance of Jones and it did not
consider the second and the third
instance so our unit cost for Jones is
1.99 because we lookup only Returns the
first
match okay moving ahead to the the next
example we have here is V lookup is case
insensitive if you consider this table
I've added another row in green so if
you see here I have a representative
name called Gil which is in proper case
or popularly known as sentence case here
I have added Gil's name
in capital letters or all in uppercase
so I want to find the total re revenue
generated by Gil the total revenue is
basically the total column let's do it
I'll write V look
up my look of value is Gil which is
actually in upper case I'll consider my
table array from the representatives
column till the end of total column or
the sales
column based on this selection my column
index number is
five comma the range lookup is false so
I'll just double click on
false close the bracket hit enter you
can see it here our V lookup function
has returned the total as
53973 which is actually the value for
this row so clearly we look up did not
consider Gil which was present at the
bottom of the table in upper case so
this shows that V lookup is clearly case
insensitive all right now moving to the
next example the V look function
supports wild cards which makes it
possible to perform a partial match on a
lookup value for instance you can use
vlookup to retrieve values from a table
after typing only part of a lookup value
to use wild cards with vlookup you must
specify the exact match by giving false
or zero for the last argument that is
range lookup now we have a question here
I want to know how much sales did the
representative whose name starts with Ki
make now here Sal represents the total
column
actually so I want to find out the
person whose name starts with
Ki so if you consider the representative
column I have one representative whose
name starts with Ki that is Kel so using
Ki as my lookup value I want to find the
total so let me show you how to use
wildcard characters and find the value
using vooka up so I'll write my function
V
lookup okay now in lookup value I'll
give
Ki after that I'm going to write Amber
scent followed
by double inverted commas then I'm going
to write a star and close the inverted
comma this means the value starts with
Ki Amber scent actually represents
concatenation and star represents
anything for followed by Ki so this is
going to be my lookup value in total
I'll give a
comma next I'll select my table array
starting from the representatives column
till the end of total column because I
want to find the sales I'll give another
comma my column index number based on
the table array we have selected is five
comma the range lookup is zero because I
want to find an exact match I close the
bracket hit enter you can see it here V
lookup has returned me
99.5 which is actually kl's
total now there's another way to do
it instead of selecting the cell in
which we have the lookup value I can
directly write it in the v lookup
function so I'll write the V lookup
function something like this so my
lookup
value I'll pass Ki within double
inverted commas because Ki is a
character value So within double
inverted commas I'm writing Ki followed
by Amber Cent which is for concatenation
followed by a
star within double inverted commas so
this is going to be my lookup values
this in total means anything that
appears after Ki will be considered as
the lookup
value again the table array I'll select
as
these rows and columns comma my column
index number would be five comma the
range lookup is zero if I close the
bracket hit enter you see we have the
same value so this is another method or
another way of using
vlookups okay now moving ahead let's
explore another feature of vlookup so if
the vlookup function cannot find a match
it returns a hash na error now if you
want you can use the if na fun function
to replace the hasna error with a
friendly message so suppose you want to
find the region in which an order was
placed on 10th of May
2018 now if the order date is not found
I want to return a message that is inv
valid date
so if you look at the order date column
we don't have any value for 10th of May
2015 you can see these values we don't
have any value corresponding to this
this date so if my vlookup function
cannot find this lookup value I'll
return invalid date so let me show you
how to write
this I'll type my vup function I'll give
my order date as 10th of May
2015 as my lookup value and then I'll
consider my table array starting from
the order date column till the end of
region
column I'll give another comma my column
index number would be two this time
based on the table array we have
selected comma I want an exact
match so I'll give zero close the
bracket and hit enter there you go it
has returned me an error now I want to
convert this error to a friendly message
saying invalid date so let me show you
how to do it I'll do it here so to
return a valid
message I'll use the if any function and
within if any function I'll give my V
lookup function so let me type if
na I'll hit
tab now for the value parameter I'll use
my V lookup function so my lookup value
is going to be the order date comma my
table array I'll select from the order
date column till the end of region
column comma my column index number is
going to be two comma my range lookup is
zero I'll close the bracket give another
comma Now if this expression results in
an error I want to display a message
that is invalid date so I'll put inv
valid date within double codes since it
is a text
message I close the bracket hit enter
you can see the result which is invalid
date now moving on to the final section
of the demo we have two-way lookup
now in the vooka function the column
index parameter is normally hardcoded as
a static number however you can also
create a dynamic column index by using
the match function to locate the right
column and this technique allows you to
create a dynamic two-way lookup matching
on both rows and
columns now let me first show you how a
match function works so
suppose I want to find the index where
unit cost column is Pres present so here
I'll use the match function I'll give my
lookup value as the unit cost column
name comma suppose I'll choose my lookup
array starting from Representatives
column till the unit cost column comma
I'll give my match type a zero for exact
match if I close the bracket hit enter
it returns me four because my array was
selected from the representatives column
till the unit cost column column and in
this array unit cost is at the fourth
index all right now using this idea
let's solve the following problem I want
to find the cost of each item sold by
Morgan so let's write our vlookup
formula I'll write
vlookup my lookup value is J5 which has
the representatives name as Morgan comma
my table array I'll select from C2 till
F12 I'll give a comma and this time I
know that my column index number is at 4
but I'll be using the match function to
find the
same so I'll write
match my lookup value is unit cost comma
my lookup array is from C1 till
F1 comma my match type is zero I close
this bracket give another comma and I'll
give my range lookup as zero close the
bracket hit enter you can see for Morgan
the unit cost is 19.99 you can verify
from the table for Morgan the unit cost
is
19.99 all right now we have another
question
here I want to find how much did Andrew
make in the central region so here I
have two lookup values one is Central
one is Andrews now looking at these two
values I want to find the
total to solve such
problems let me first create another
table I'll place the table somewhere
here okay so let me just paste the table
here all right now I'll create another
column where I'll merge the values of
region and representatives so here let
me create another column okay I'll just
name this column as
region
rep all right now this
column I'll use the concatenation
operator so I'll Select East use Amber
Cent and then select Jones I'll hit
enter now the same thing I'll just
duplicate it for the other rows as well
so I have my new column created Now
using this table I can easily solve the
problem now to find the total I'll write
my vlookup
formula so my lookup value will be a
combination of
j11 Amber
Cent K1 comma while table array will
start from the region rep which has the
values of region and rep combined
till the last
column and from this table array my
column index number is five and my range
lookup is zero if I close the bracket
hit enter you can see for central region
which is this one and for Andrew's
representative the total is 149. 25 all
right right now we are done with our
demo let's have a quick glance at what
all we did in this demo okay so first of
all we saw our data set which was a
sales data set that we used then we
started with our first example to see
how we look up performs an exact match
we also saw how using the formulas Tab
and lookup and reference you can write V
lookup in another way so you can use the
function arguments to give your V look
up parameters next we saw how vup
performs an approximate match so we had
Matt and raw which were not present in
the representatives column after that we
saw an important property of V lookup
that is V lookup only looks to the right
followed by V lookup only Returns the
first match following which we saw that
V lookup is case insensitive so here we
had added a new row where Gil was
present in upper case but still we look
up found the total revenue for Gill
which was in sentence case or proper
case next we saw how we can use Wild
Card characters to use V lookups and
here we saw how to use an if any
function along with v lookup and finally
we saw how to use two V lookups choose
from over 300 in demand skills and get
access to 1,000 plus hours of video
content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more now we are on
the sheet of Microsoft Excel and here
you can see some data on my
sheet that is employee name employee ID
and salary so here we are going to
perform our horizontal lookup but before
that let me show you that this
particular drop down menu so this
particular drop down menu has all the
names of the employees in this
particular table and we have created
this using data validation in Excel if
you want to create the drop down menu
use just like this then feel free to
check out our data validation in Excel
tutorial link to which is in the
description box below now let's try to
implement H lookup in Excel so here we
have employee name but we want to find
out the employee ID so for that let's
create the hookup now for that equals to
hookup now the first one is a look up
value so this one is the cell which is
the employee name now after that the
table array we have to select all the
table arrays
here
now the row index number so the employee
ID is in row index number two according
to the table so for that provide two and
close the bracket and before closing
brackets you might want to give the
exact match so for exact match select
false and close the bracket press enter
and there you go and if you select check
then you'll find the employee ID of
check and if you select Jerry you'll
find the employee ID of Jerry reflecting
here now similarly let's find out the
salary of all the employees using hookup
so equals
hookup and look up value that happens to
be the name of the employee now the
table
array and next we have uh row index
number that is salary happens to be the
third row in the table so three and
exact match close the bracket and enter
so now if you change the values in this
particular dropdown menu you'll find the
employee ID and their particular salary
so Jack happens to be carrying the
employee ID as 10001 and his salary is
10,000 so similarly let's try to find
out Peter's employee ID and salary so
there you go 105 and 50,000 salary so
that's how you use H lookup in Excel
here you can see the first chart so this
particular data is converted into a
table format to avoid confusion while
you're fixing the data so here you can
see the name of the employee employee ID
Department salary and date of joining
and here you can see the salary column
and the bonus percentage of each and
every employee based on their salaries
now coming to the new data table and
here on the table two which is an
updated table here you can find we're
going to find out the department of the
employee and the current Department of
employee and the bonus percentage based
on his or her salary so why are we
finding current Department again so here
you can see that we have an intern Emily
who has joined in the year 2020 but
recently she got promoted as a developer
so her department has been changed from
Department intern to Department
developer in 2021 so that's what we're
going to find out here in the current
Department using X lookup now let's
start to implement xlup so for that
equals to X lookup
and for lookup you can see if we need to
find out the lookup value lookup array
return array and all the other two are
not important right now but you can use
them to get some exact matches in the
future we'll also use that in the future
for now let's try to use the first three
parameters that is lookup value lookup
array and written array so the lookup
value is the name of the employee Mary
and lookup array is right here which is
this one now we are going to select the
lookup array then comma and uh we're
going to look up the department so this
is the department lookup aray and that's
all we
need close the bracket and press enter
okay I think we missed out the lookup
value so the employee uh or the lookup
value which we required was missed so
I've added it here so that is the lookup
value the first one which is Mary and
there you go PR enter and you have the
department here now let's add it to all
the rows and here you have all the rows
and all the data related to all the
employees now we will find out the
current Department as you can see here
you have Emily as intern which is the
old data but what if you needed the
latest data that is the developer in the
year 2021 right for that you might want
to to work the X lookup formula a little
bit so let's try that X
lookup look lookup value which is the
same and comma Now where you have to
look for the array that is lookup array
this one and the return array which
happens to be this
one and
next you can find the exact match for
this one so that's all right exact match
and here comes the important part where
you have to search last to first by
default X lookup searches for first to
last that is like this in the starting
place to the last place so that's the
reason why we had Emily as intern so now
if we give last to first then it
retrieves the latest Theta where Emily
will be shown as developer now select
that and now you can close the brackets
and press enter so let's add that to all
the rows there you go now you can see
Emily Clark Peter and James all they
have got their updated job profiles as
you can see in the original data Emily
is a developer now so is Clark who was
originally a tester and he got promoted
to development team in 2021 similarly
Peter became a senior Finance executive
in 2021 and James the manager of sales
now let's try to find out the bonus for
all these employees based on their
salary so this one is quite simple so X
lookup now the lookup value is their
existing salary comma and the bonus part
so the lookup array is the salary
range then here is another important
point so here you might want to find the
exact match but finding the exact match
will not help you here you might want to
declare another type of value where you
can get exact match or next smaller item
so you'll understand it why I'm
selecting that so now let's close the
bracket and enter
so so now we have the bonus values now
let's add the bonus value to all the
factors all the rows I mean so you can
see we have different variety of
salaries that is 38,000 22,000 39 Etc
but here in the ranges we have provided
10 20 30 40 and 50 so what if the value
is between 30 and 20 that's when you
want the less number right that's when
you want the number which is equivalent
to 30 or less than 30 which happens to
be 15% so that's how it has worked here
that is 0 .5% bonus to the actual salary
now we are on our Excel sheet here you
can see the employee names and employee
IDs of different employees from
different zones let us imagine that the
blue one is from East Green one is from
West and the black one is from or the
purple one is from South and the orange
one is from North so this data is a
little small but what if you had a data
with 100 hundreds or thousands of rows
including all the employee names
employee IDs or another relevant data
type like sales of an employee and his
employee ID and you were supposed to
combine all the data from all the four
different zones into one single sheet it
would consume a lot of time right so
recently Microsoft has released some
latest updates based on arrays and datas
so one of those is vstack function in
Excel so how to use it since it is a
latest function I recommend you to go to
the file menu and in the file menu you
can navigate to account and in the
account you can see the option of update
options then you can select update now
and your Microsoft Office will be
updated to the latest version and you'll
get access to the latest functions in
Excel and all the other office related
things like P on presentation Etc now we
going to implement the v stack function
in Excel it is completely simple all you
need to do is equals to stack and then
select the data remember to select the
data from column A and cell two or the
row two we are not selecting the
employee name and employee ID we are
just selecting the data now separate
them by comma then again this one here
this set and again this
one and again lastly this particular
last set
now close the bracket and press
enter and there you go you have all the
employee names and their respective
employee IDs all together in one data
set so this is how you use wack function
in Excel as we speak you might wonder
what it takes to become an expert data
analyst if you are an aspiring data
analyst with at least one year of domain
experience and looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learns
postgraduate program in data analysis
from Pur University in collaboration
with IBM should be your right choice for
more details on this course head
straight to our homepage and type in
postgraduate program in data analysis or
simply click on the link in the
description box below with that in mind
over to our training experts some PDF
data into Excel now you can see the PDF
document which I'm looking to convert
from PDF to excel so this particular PDF
document has a table so this is the
statewise GST collections that happened
during March of 2020 now we need to
convert this tabula data from PDF format
to excel format now we are on the
Microsoft Excel now to initiate the
process we might want to choose a blank
workbook for this so now we are at the
blank workbook and the complete sheet is
empty now let's go into the data option
in the toolbar and and in the data
option of the toolbar we
have the ribbon of get and transform
data in this ribbon you can see get data
option select that and you can see
various options here from file from
database from Azure from other sources
Etc now we need the first option that is
from file and in that we have a dropdown
and in that drop down you might want to
select the PDF if you have have a Json
file you can also choose from a Json and
if you have the data from XML you can
choose that and even you can extract the
data from text or CSV as well now we
need the PDF option so select the PDF
Now navigate where your file is existing
so my file is on the desktop and now let
me select the PDF document select import
now Excel will automatically analyze the
tab data in the PDF format and give you
the results
now according to excel there are
multiple Tabo formats table one table
two so basically this table is one and
the same so all the 29 states are fixed
in one table itself but since the PDF is
divided in sheets this particular
document is considering the first table
as a separate table and the table which
is present in the third page as a
separate table so we have table one
table two and there are a few more
tables which Excel is assuming that it
might be table but it's not and another
table which is page number 002 it is a
table and another one is right here now
there is an option of selecting all the
tables all together at once or you can
select only one table which you want to
select so if you select multiple items
Excel will automatically give you an
option of choosing your tables you can
just take and select the tables you want
or you can directly select the table you
want on on your Excel
sheet so right now let's try to select
multiple tables so I'll be selecting 1 2
four and five and this particular one is
not a table so I'm eliminating that now
you might want to choose the load option
so Excel is now loading the
[Music]
data now all the data has been
successfully
loaded
now yeah it is giving us a notification
that all the been successfully loaded
and now just right click on it and here
choose the option load to and here
select table option and if you want the
data to be uh you know loaded to a new
worksheet you can choose that and select
okay now you can see all the data is
been successfully loaded in the form of
tabular format in the new Excel
sheet similarly let's try to load
another
page in the table
format new
worksheet select
okay and the third
sheet now get ready to impress your boss
by converting all the PDF data into
Excel sheet just in a matter of few
seconds with few steps and there you go
all the four tables have been loaded
successfully in the form of excel in
just a few steps now this is how you
convert PDF to
excel now for this particular tutorial
we will be using the student data set
now let's get back to the Practical mode
and start our Microsoft Excel now we are
in the Microsoft Excel and as you can
see on my sheet okay let me expand
this so as you can see on my screen we
have the data set belonging to students
so we have 10 students and every one of
them has name role number class blood
group and marks Etc and at the end we
have the percentage and as you can see
we have the percentage in terms of float
values and we have a lot of decimal
values like eight and above so what if
you wanted to just have one or two
digits after the actual percentage like
80.6 or 80. 66 right it would be a
little bit more or good to read right so
that's what a roundoff actually means so
now let's work on having rounded off
values for the percentage now let's
create a new
column let's name it as
um
round
of
percentage
great so to actually perform the
roundoff uh formula we do have a
predefined method for that for that you
just have to type
in equals to
round and there you go we have round up
and round down so both of them perform
the same operation let's select a round
up and this is the m column and the row
number is three so we'll have to press
M3 and the number of values after the
decimal point for now let's select um
one and there you go press enter and the
value should be rounded off now 80. 66
is being rounded off to
80.7 now now when you drag the cell to
the all the rules then you can see all
the values will be rounded off here you
can see 75.1 16 has been rounded off to
75.2 and 82.3 3 is been rounded off to
82.4 so we end up with having rounded
off values so for example uh let us
imagine that you wanted to create one
single cell for all the employees in
your company which stores the
first name second name or last name
including the email IDs at one place
right if you want to do so like let us
let us let me show you how it looks like
so let me copy this
here then that's the first name now it's
your second
name along with the email ID now let us
imagine that you wanted to store all the
employees in the same way right so you
can do this by using combine op
operation in Excel now all it takes is
just a simple formula that is equals to
and the first cell
address that is
A2 and you can use an ample Center
sign now you can use the next cell
reference that is
B2 and then colon and the last cell
address that is E2 now press
enter
so when you press enter or tab you will
get this particular answer but this data
is completely uh in a state where you
can't understand it right the first name
last name and the email ID has got
combined all together so you want to use
some spaces right so all you need to do
is just make a little modification to
this particular existing data so you can
press another ENT and include spaces
and then you can separate the email ID
and the name with some
colon so now we have separated the first
two cells that is the first name and the
last name with the space using the
ampers sense and then again we have used
an ENT to include the colon and see that
we have also included a space between
the colon marks that it's gets separated
cleanly and now let's try to press Tab
and see the result so there you go the
first name and the second name is
separated by space and the email ID and
the complete name is separated by a
colon now you can use this to all the
cells and there you go all the first
name last name and the email IDs have
been printed here so that's how you use
the combine operation in Excel let's get
started with our onepoint agenda that is
stated F function in Excel now we might
have to switch to the Practical mode for
that now we have started our Microsoft
Excel and and here we have our empty
worksheet so dated IF function is
majorly used to find the differences
between two individual dates so it is
also called as dated if by a few people
and a few people also reference it to
date diff that is date difference so
anything is good now to find the
difference between any two dates let's
select a few dates so the first date
would be uh let us imagine that you're
an employee and you wanted to find out
how many years that you've been working
with an organization so for that you
might want to need today and the date
where you join the company right so it
might be date of joining and
today so what's the difference right so
let us imagine that you join the
organization somewhere around
2010 and
today so for today can you can give any
particular
date let us imagine that uh today is 1st
of January 2021 or
2022 now we have up both the dates that
is the joining date and the current date
which can be the current date so the day
can be anything so you might be watching
this on different date as well so the
date of that day for today would be a
little different so we'll imagine the
today's date as an imaginary dat now we
might want to find the difference that
is in terms of ears so you wanted to
find the difference in terms of ears so
here you can find the difference in
terms of years days and months as well
so currently let's try to find out the
difference in terms of years so for
years you might want to specify the
third parameter in the data function as
why if you wanted once you have to give
the M as the third parameter and if you
want to find the days you might want to
give d as the third parameter uh so we
have discussed the third parameter so
what are the first two parameters right
so the first two parameters are the
first date and the last date so the
first date in this situation is your
date of joining and the last date or the
final date which you w't here is your
today so let's find the difference so
for that equals to so it can be dated if
or date
diff so date if and the first date which
is the A2 and comma the last state that
is B2 and your parameter third parameter
in terms of years that is why close the
bracket and press enter so there you go
you have your date here so it's been
like 11 years that you're working with
your organization so that's how you find
out the differences so we have 11 is
because uh we did not finish the 12th
year completely so if we had given the
month as uh maybe six where we have
finished our total years then it will
automatically change to 12 years so you
can see on my screen we are on the Excel
spreadsheet and on my spreadsheet you
can see dates in column A and different
formats in column C D E and F
respectively Now by default the data
type or the data present in the a column
will be considered as general and there
are a few situations where even if you
try to format the date in your format
like you know the customized format you
may not be able to do it because it's
still under the general data type so for
that for being on the safer side what we
will do is select the data and navigate
to the data toolbar and in that you have
the text to columns option press that
and remember to have the delimited icon
you know you might be having the dash as
your icon or slash as your icon for the
Del limited thing and select that and
next next and here you can see right
it's in general mode so you can press on
date and DMI will be your date format
that is date month and year now click on
finish so it's been formatted now now
let's copy the same data and paste it in
all the four formats so that we'll see
the difference formats that we can
change to or customize to right so there
you go let's expand the columns a little
bit now we have day month and year so
now you might want to change a couple of
things right for example you wanted to
change okay let's see the menu so the
way is to select the sales and right
click and select the format sales option
and in here you can see the date
function and in here you can see
different types of modifications that
you can do to your data right
so you might want to also change your
dates based on the location so right now
we are in India and imagine if you
wanted to you know change something
based on us or if you if you're having
your client in us and he wants the dates
in US format you can also change that so
here you can see English United States
and press on that press okay and you can
see it's been changed to us format where
you have years in the first place months
in the second place and dates in the
last place right
and now let us imagine that uh your
client does not want the dates all he
needs is just months right you can also
do that get back to the format sales
option go to custom and here instead of
uh you know uh month date and year all
you can do is just write down month and
year and select okay so you'll have only
month and you're not the dates now your
client is being a little more you know
he wants a little more detail here and
he wants you to add a lot of granularity
to your data which includes day time Etc
everything right so you can also do that
so the same way go to format sales
custom and here I think it's in date
itself so let's navigate a little yeah
here so you have the day date month and
year press okay so there you go right so
that's how you can do it and now let's
try a little a little bit more if you
have a few more options
pending so go to format
sales and
custom and you also have
timings so here you have date month year
and timings press okay and there you
have all the timings as well so since
these dates are you know I created them
just a few moments ago to keep it simple
so I did not have have to add the
timings here so if you are Keen about
adding the timings you can also do that
for example if you wanted to add the
timings of the employees logged in and
logged out you can also do that using
the same format we have four different
sheets of the sales so the first sheet
is the West Zone next is South Zone East
Zone and central zone so all this data
belongs to one single sheet that is
Superstore data set so I have
categorized or I have taken a part of
the data which belongs to central region
South Region west region and east region
now we are going to use all these four
sheets and create one single sheet which
is the pivot table of all the four
sheets now without further Ado let's
start the process now for that we might
want to use the shortcut key that is alt
D now press P now this starts the pivot
chart
wizard now here we have to choose the
option multiple consolidation
ranges then then click on
next and here you can see the pivot
table is clicked by default now we'll go
to next now here click I will create
page fields or the pivot chart wizard
will automatically create if you want
that to create for you now click on next
now here let's select the
range now I'll be selecting the
range add
it now next we'll Select
East
it followed by that we have
South and finally we have
West now we will name these according to
the
regions so the first one will be
West
next one will be
South next one will be
East and the last one will be
Central click on next and here select
new worksheet and
finish and there you go you have the
pivot table here now you might want to
change the submission value so click
anywhere on the pivot table and change
it from count to
sum so that you have the summation of
the total number of sales subcategory
sales and grand total of sales Etc now
here you can see all option now let's
select Central and you'll get the
details of the central region the grand
total and the sales happening quantity
of sales Etc now here can you can see
the furniture office supplies technology
and the grand total all in one single
sheet now let's get back to the original
sheet so as you can see this is the
original sheet and in the original sheet
you can see various more
categories which is the which is the
shipment mode customer customer segment
country City State uh and you also have
U product name subcategory Etc so if you
had added all these into this sheet you
can also create a separate option of
adding myu details to your pivot table
so that is how the pivot table is
created using multiple sheets so slices
in Excel are software filters used along
with Excel tables or Excel pivot tables
over a large amount of data not just
filtering out data but slices also help
you with an easy understanding of the
information being extracted Ed and
displayed on the screen now Microsoft
Excel slices are compatible with Windows
and Mac and toou operating systems now
let us understand how to implement
slicers in Excel so for that we might
want to get back to the Practical mode
that is starting our Microsoft
Excel now we are on our Excel sheet and
as you can see on my screen there is
some data available on the Excel
spreadsheet and this table is not just
just any table this table from Microsoft
Excel is been converted into an actual
table as you know by default Excel
considers all the data which has been
inserted into the spreadsheet as a
database and to implement the slices in
Excel we might want to create or convert
the format of database into a normal
table for that you can select all your
data and just press contrl T and that
will allow you an option called convert
the data into table now since this table
is already converted as a table we can
directly start implementing or inserting
slices into the
spreadsheet now for that select all your
data then going to the insert
option and in the insert ribbon you can
see the filters group and in the filters
group select the option called slicer
now you will be provided with multiple
options since we have the columns
employee ID employee name Zone
designation Department salary employees
date of birth and employees state of
joining so we can choose any of the
options available according to our
columns and create the slices now let me
select the first one that is Zone next
designation department and let's also
select employee
name now press okay and there you go we
have our
slicers now let us try to rearrange
these slices all you can do is just
select and drag them
up and done now let us imagine that we
want to see or take a look at the
employees who are working in the EAS
Zone then we have the information
displayed on the screen who are working
in the East Zone they are Jack Tony bner
Fred Etc and their Department
designation etc etc all on one single
screen so this really helps you while
you're presenting your data in a
presentation now for a change let's try
to select the department now if your
client wants to select the data from
only analytics Department then you might
want to select on the analytics key key
on the department slicer and there you
go you have an employee called Luke hops
who works in the East Zone and his
department is analytics and his
designation is contract based and the
salary he is getting is
65,000 now
similarly uh you can see that we have
only selected analytics and your client
also wants data from it support now you
can see that analytics is gone but what
if you want both analytics and it
support then you have an option called
select multiple then you can select
analytics and it support and if you want
HR you can also do that and in the zone
if you want West along with East then
you can do the same east and west and
you have all the employee details and in
the designation let's try to select U
senior
traine okay select multiple senior
trainy and manager so that's how you do
it so that's how it's done and that's
how you implement slicers in Excel to
simplify the filtering options using
slicers during a presentation and with
that we have come to an end of this
tutorial on slicers in
Excel Excel supports a number of
shortcut keys that you can use to speed
up your work and make your work
efficient these shortcuts make working
with spreadsheets a little easier now
the question arises do I need to
memorize the shortcut keys the answer is
no the keyboard shortcuts in Excel helps
you perform data analysis better and
faster but it would be an advantage if
you can remember a few of
them now let's begin by looking at some
of the important workbook related
shortcuts so we will see how to create a
new workbook open an existing workbook
and save a spreadsheet so that you don't
lose any data or calculations that you
have done towards the end you will see
how you can toggle between different
sheets in a
workbook now to open an Excel workbook
on Windows you can just search for Excel
here you can see this is the Excel app
I'll click on
it and you can see there's the Home tab
new tab from here you can open any
existing workbook as well so let me go
to the new tab and open a blank workbook
now Mark here on the top it says book
one- Excel now if you were to create a
new workbook the shortcut is control +
n now Mark this so if I hit control+
n you can see it has opened a new
workbook called book two I can show it
to you here can see there are two
workbooks book one and book
two so the shortcut to open a new
workbook is control+ n
now if you want to open an existing
workbook that is present in your system
the shortcut is crol O So if I hit crol
o you can go to browse and check for
your Excel file that is present on your
system let me go to the desktop and
search
for Excel
workbooks you can see I have two Excel
files here let me select the C 19 file
I'll click on
open I'll enable
editing there you go so we have our
existing workbook opened on
Excel now if you want to save a workbook
or a spreadsheet the shortcut is
control+ s this is very simple you use
it in other editors as well now
suppose I duplicate this column I use
contrl
C go on
top and hit contrl
V now to save this spreadsheet I'll just
press contrl
s you can see the workbook is saved now
you can also click on this one which
says save control+
s so I don't need this column actually
so let me go ahead and delete this
column and now to close the current
workbook the shortcut is control+ W so
if I hit control W it will ask me do you
want to save this file or not I'll say
don't save and it will close that
current file next if you want to close
Excel the shortcut key is control
F4 now if I hitr
F4 you can see my book one is closed
closed so I can go ahead and close the
workbook now let me go ahead and open a
workbook again so I'll search for
Excel and click on
it I'll go to a blank
workbook now if you want to move to next
sheet you can use control page down now
in this current workbook we have only
one sheet now let me create two more
sheets and come to sheet one
now if you want to move to the next
sheet the shortcut is control page down
so if I hit control page down you can
see I'm in sheet two now if I again hit
control page down I have come to sheet
three next if you want to move on to the
previous sheet the shortcut is control
page up so let me hit control page up
you can see I'm in sheet two now and if
I hit control page up once again I've
come to sheet
one
now to get a little more clarity on this
let me open a workbook that has multiple
sheets or multiple tables so I'll hit
control o and I'll look for my sample
Superstore data set click on it you can
see this data set has three tables the
first one is the orders table the second
one is the returns table which has the
detail about the orders that were
returned and the next table is of people
table that basically has person and the
region to which the person belong to so
let me come to my audits table now if I
want to move to my returns and people
table for that I can hit control page
down which is to move to the next sheet
so if I hit control page down see I am
in the returns table now if I hit
control page down once again I've come
to my people table if you want to move
back I'll hit control page up
you can see I am in my returns table if
I hit control P once again I've come
back to my audits
table now there are a few other
shortcuts that I want to tell you here
so suppose you want to switch between
different tabs that are present in the
ribbon you can do that as well with the
help of shortcut keys so in Excel this
is the ribbon which has different tabs
like the file tab Home tab insert draw
page layout and so on
now currently we are in the Home tab if
you want to move to the data tab the
shortcut is alt a so if I hit alt a you
can see we have come to the data tab now
if you want to go to the view tab the
shortcut is alt
W you can see we have come to the view
Tab and if you want to move to the
formula tab the shortcut is alt M so if
I hit alt M you can see we we have come
to the formula
tab now let me open another Excel file
where we have listed all the shortcut
keys that we are covering in this video
so let me go ahead and do that so I'll
go to file and under
open I'll click on
browse and under desktop I look for my
Excel shortcut keys file I'll click on
open
so this is the Excel sheet we have
created for you for your
reference you can pause the video to
note the shortcut keys we have covered
so far if you want to get access to this
Excel sheet please share your email
address in the chat section we'll send
it to you over email so far we have
covered all the workbook related
shortcuts so these are the shortcuts we
have covered so far that I'm
highlighting
here now let's move back to our slides
and and see what we have
next so you can see we have our cell
formatting shortcuts up
next now here I will tell you the
different shortcuts that can be applied
to a cell such as editing a cell
aligning cell contents adding a border
to a cell adding an outline to all the
selected cells Etc so let's go ahead and
do these
operations
so I'll go to my
book
one and the first shortcut that we'll
see is how to edit a cell for
example there are certain values such as
10 20
30 and if I scroll
down like this and now if you want to
edit the cells you can just select that
cell here I have selected A4 cell you
can see on the top and hit F2 to edit
the cell so if I hit F2 you can see I
can edit the cell and make it say 40
similarly I'll hit F2 again and make
this as
50 and so
on now you can also edit the formula
that is present in a Cell so let me use
a formula say We'll calculate the
sum and I'll choose a 1 to A8 and find
the sum now if I select this and click
on
F2 I can change the formula as
well let's say
average I'll hit enter you can see it
has calculated the average from A1 to
A8 now if you want to copy paste cells
the shortcut is very simple is control+
C and control+ V now suppose I want to
copy set cell A4 I can just hit contrl C
and I'll hit contrl V to paste it
similarly you can also select a range of
cells and hit contrl C and contrl V to
paste it similarly you can also copy
paste different
cells from other worksheets so I have
come to my sample Superstore workbook
and let me select a few
cells and
I can copy it by hitting contrl C I'll
move back and I can paste it control
V next if you want to bold and italicize
the font values in a Cell you can use
contrl B and control I respectively so
if I want to
bold
suppose the headings or the column names
I can use control B can see it's
Bold And if I want to italicize certain
values let me select this one I can use
contr I to italicize it I'll hit contr I
you can see it's
italicized now you can also underline
the cell contents so let me show you how
to do that for this purpose we use
control+ U so let me select this cell
and I'll hit control U you can see
it has added an underline similarly let
me do it for one more
cell I'll hit cr+ U you can see it has
put an underline to this cell as
well now if you want to fill colors to
certain cells the shortcut you can use
is alt plus h plus
h so let me show you if I select this
cell and hit alt HH you can see it has
it has prompted me to select a color
I'll select this blue color and you can
see you have filled a color to this cell
similarly you can fill color to a range
of cells as well I have selected these
cells and let me hit alt
HH and this time I'll select this green
color you can see we have filled all the
cells with green
color now if you want to add a b order
to a cell the shortcut is alt + H+ B now
let me
select this cell
40 and hit alt+ H +
B so it has prompted me to select the
type of border that you want now let me
select I want a top
border you can see
here it has put a top border to cell
B5 and now let me choose cell E6 and
again hit alt
HB and this time let's say I'll select
all borders you can see the cell has all
borders across
it now if you were to remove the outline
border the shortcut is control + shift
plus underscore so if I want to remove
this top border from cell B5 I'll hit
control shift
uncore you can see the top border is no
more there similarly let's remove all
border from cell E6 I'll hit control
shift uncore you can see the border is
gone now if you want to add outline to
selected cells the shortcut is control+
shift plus Amber scent so let me select
the cells that I had colored just now
and if I hit control Shift Amber sent
you can see it has added a
border to the selected cells I can show
it to you here as well let me select it
and
hit control shift Ament can see it has
added a border to all the selected
cells another thing I want to show you
here is if you want to move to the
previous cell the sort cut is shift tab
so if I select this cell and hit shift
tab it will take me back to the next
cell which is E8 if I hit shift tab
again it takes me to C8 next is B8 then
it's
A8 now if you want to move to the next
cell the shortcut is tab so if I hit tab
it will take me to the next
cell now if you want to to select the
cells on the right the shortcut is
control shift right arrow so initially
if I select cell H2 and now I want to
select all the cells on the right I can
just hit control shift right arrow so as
you can see it has selected all the
cells on the right similarly if you want
to select all the cells on the left the
shortcut is control shift left
Arrow as you can see it has selected all
the
cells now if you want to select the
column from the selected cell to the end
of the table the shortcut is control
shift down
arrow so I'll hit control shift down
arrow you can see it has selected the
entire
column now if you want to select the
data above the selected
cell the shortcut is control shift up
Arrow so I'll hit control shift up Arrow
you can see it has selected all the
cells that were present on on top of
it
yeah let me again take you to the Excel
sheet that is all the list of shortcuts
discussed in this
video so I'll go to file
and I'll open Excel shortcut
keys so now we have looked at all the
self formatting
shortcuts that I'm
highlighting again if you want to get
access to this Excel sheet please drop
in your email ID will share it over
email next we'll be discussing about
some additional cell formatting
shortcuts so up next we will see some
additional cell formatting
shortcuts here we will have a look at
how to add a comment to a cell so
comments are used to give extra
information about a cell value you can
also learn how to find a value and
replace it with another value in the
spreadsheet then we'll see how to
activate a filter insert the current
date current time and also add a
hyperlink to a cell finally we'll see
how to apply a format to the data in a
Cell now let me go to my sample
Superstore data
set so this is my sample Superstore data
set now if I need to add a comment to a
cell the shortcut key I will use is
shift
F2 so let me select Brina Hoffman and
hit shift F2 you can see my comment box
has appeared now let me give a comment
like
Brina is from LA or Los Angeles you can
see Brina Hoffman is from Los Angeles
now if I select this you can see our
comment
next if you want to display find and
replace a value from a cell or a range
of of cells you can use control+
H so let me select control+
H you can see our find and replace box
has
appeared and here if I want to change
the name of say
suppose
BR to something like
Angela I'll first select s
for Brina so here I'm typing what I need
to find that is Brina and I'll replace
it
with Angela
suppose now I'll hit replace
all you'll get a popup say all done we
made 48 Replacements if I click okay and
select close you can see the name Brina
was changed to
Angela
Excel has another important feature
which is to filter your data based on
certain values now let me show you how
you can apply a
filter so I'll select this city column
and I'll go to my data Tab and here you
can see we have filter I'll choose this
now we have applied a filter to our city
column to show you more can see here it
has all the city name
listed and if I uncheck this select all
and I'll select certain cities and click
okay it will filter my data only for
those
cities use control Z to undo
it and now if you want to activate a
filter the shortcut key that I'll use is
alt down arrow so if I Hil Alt down
arrow you can see my activate filter box
has appeared I choose
cancel if I click on a particular cell
in this city column and hit alt down
arrow again you can see the list of
cities
here now I'll move back to my book one
and I'll show you how you can insert the
current date now to insert the current
date in a particular cell the shortcut
I'll use is control+
semicolon so now if I hit control+
semicolon it will give me the current
date you can see this is our current
date that is 9th of June similarly you
can go ahead and get the current time as
well so the shortcut for that is control
shift colon so if you hit control shift
colon it will give you the current time
as well
also Excel allows you to insert a
hyperlink now in order to insert a
hyperlink you can use control+ K so if I
hit control+ K you can see the insert
hyperlink box has appeared now you can
give any address here so let me go to
Google and say W3 schools I'll copy this
link and I'll paste it in the address
add
section and here on the top where it
says text to display I'll write W3
schools
website now if I hit okay you can see we
have inserted a hyperlink and if I click
on this it will take me to the W3
schools
website so it opens up in my Google
Chrome you can see this is the W3
Schools
website similarly let me insert one more
link so I'll go ahead and click control
K and this time let's say I'll choose
simply loar website I'll select this
website address and here in the address
section I'll paste the URL and on top
I'll
write simply learn
website which is my text that it will
display I click on okay if
I click on this cell it will take me to
my simply learns
website going
back now I'll tell you how to apply
certain formats so let's see how you can
apply a currency format so you can
see we have some numerical values here
I'll select this values and if I hit
control shift
dollar now these numbers have been
converted into currency
format we have all in the form of
rupees similarly if you want
to convert a particular cell value say 3
into percentage you can use control
shift and percentage symbol so it has
converted into 30% suppose it's
0.6 and and on this if I select control
shift
percentage it has converted into
60% another shortcut key that you can
use is alt Q or alt plus Q this will go
to the tell me what you want to do box
so if I hit alt
Q you can
see it has taken me to the tell me what
you want to do box if I select a pivote
table it will ask you you to give the
range and select where you want to place
your pavot
table I'll hit
cancel now moving
ahead if you have enjoyed watching this
video so far consider subscribing to our
simply learn YouTube channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an
update let's see what we have next so
now we look at some of the important row
and column formatting shortcuts
here we will learn how to delete rows
and columns hide and unhide selected
rows and columns as well as group and
ungroup rows and
columns I'll go to my sample Superstore
data set now if you want to select an
entire
row I'll click on a particular cell and
if I want to select row
7 I'll just hit shift space so you can
see it has selected my entire
row similarly if you want to select an
entire column you can hit control space
so if I hit control space it has
selected my order date
column now to select the entire
worksheet you can use control shift
space so I'll hit control shift
space you can see it has selected my
entire workshe
sheet now if you want to move to the
edge of the worksheet you can use
control right
arrow so this is the edge of the
worksheet now if you want to delete a
column you can use alt plus h + D+ C or
alt HD
C now let's say I want want to delete a
specific
column let me choose a
column say the discount column I want to
delete it so I can use alt
HDC so let me press alt
HDC you can see the discount column is
gone I'll use control Z to bring it
back now
if you want to delete a row you can use
shift plus space to select that entire
row so let me hit shift space now I've
selected my row 10 and then if I hit
control minus it will delete row
10 and see row ID 9 is deleted if I undo
it I have it
back moving ahead now if you want to
hide a selected Row the shortcut is
control 9 so let's say I have
selected row 11 and I want to hide it I
can just use control 9 to hide
it now you can see we have hidden that
particular row now if you want to unhide
that selected Row the shortcut is
control shift 9 so I'll hit control
shift 9 to unhide it
you see we have that row
back
similarly you can also hide a selected
column now to hide a selected column
let's say I want to hide first name
column so I can use control 0 so if I
hit control 0 you can see we have hidden
the first name
column now to unhide that selected
column we can use contrl + shift plus Z
0 or control shift 0 so if I hit control
shift
0 you see the shortcut did not work let
me try it once again control shift 0
it's not
working so for that you need to change
the settings by going to the control
panel so let me search for my control
panel I'll select it and now I'll search
for language here
let
me search for
language I'll click on
it I'll go to advanced
settings and then I'll click
on change language bar hot
keys in
this here I'll select change key
sequence and
then under switch keyboard layout I'll
choose not assigned and click on okay
I'll apply and click on okay and then
I'll close
it now if I hit control shift 0 it will
unhide my selected
column moving ahead now if you want to
group rows or columns the shortcut key
for it is alt shift right
arrow now suppose I have
selected these two cells and I want to
group this cells so I can hit alt shift
right arrow so you can see the group box
has appeared and I have selected rows if
I click on okay you can see here we have
grouped both the rows now if you want to
ungroup the rows the shortcut for it is
alt shift left Arrow Arrow so I'll hit
alt shift left arrow and select rows
I'll click on
okay to ungroup the
rows now let me take you back to our
reference
sheet so now we have covered all the row
and column formatting shortcuts that you
can see
here now let me move back to our
slides
now we are into the final section of our
shortcut keys here we will cover the
shortcut keys you can use in a pivote
table in Microsoft Excel a pivote table
is a table of Statistics that summarizes
your data for example you have sales
data for different regions and for
different products using a pivote table
you can summarize the data by region and
find the average sales per region the
maximum and minimum sales per region to
total sales made for each region and for
each category of products Etc it allows
you to summarize and show only relevant
data in your reports I'll create a peot
table and show you different shortcuts
to group poot table items ungroup poot
table items then we'll see how to hide
peot table item create a peot chart on
the same sheet and create a pivote chart
on a new sheet now let me go to Excel
and create a pivote table using my
Corona virus data
set
[Music]
so I'll select file and I'll open a
file I'll choose my covid-19 data
set so you can see we have our Corona
virus data
set it has the date column the day
column month year the total number of
cases that have come up in each country
the total number of deaths that were
reported country territory code and we
have the continent as well now let me
show you how you can create a PO table
first so I'll select my table and under
insert I'll choose P
table I have my table range selected
then I'll choose existing worksheet to
place my P
table I'll select a sell and click on
okay just squiz
this
and I'll sorten this column as
well
now I want to
drag my countries and territories onto
rows so you can see we
have all the countries here and
then I'll drag
the ke's column onto values and
similarly The Depths column onto values
as
well if I close this and let me squeeze
it further you can see we have our poot
table ready it has all the country names
and the total sum of the cases and the
total sum of deaths that were reported
in each
country let's use this poot table and
apply some Shortcut key Keys now first
to group poot table items the shortcut
key that I can use is alt shift right
arrow so let's select a few items from
this poot table I have selected four
rows and if I hit alt shift right
arrow you can see we have created a
group it says group one and it
has four countries and the tottal cases
as well as the total total number of
TS now if you want to ungroup the poot
table items you can use alt shift left
Arrow so let me use alt shift left
Arrow so first I have to select this
group and use alt shift left Arrow you
can see we have ungrouped the P table
items now if you want to hide a pivote
table item you can use control minus
so let's say I want to hide the values
for Afghanistan I'll use control minus
to hide
it see Afghanistan is no more there in
this SPO table to unhide let me just use
control Z it's
back similarly if you want to create a
pivote chart based on the pivote table
on the same sheet you can use alt
F1 so let me hit alt F1
1 close this and let me hit alt
F1 there you go we have our pivote
chart ready on the Sham sheet itself so
you can see there's a blue line and
there's orange line as well the Blue
Line represents the number of cases and
the Orange Line represents the sum of
depths this chart depicts that United
States has the highest number of cases
as of
now and then you can see we
have Hungary Iraq then there's Portugal
and other countries as
well let me delete
it also if you want to create a pivote
chart on a new worksheet the shortcut
you can use is f11 so you just have to
hit
f11 so let me hit f11 you can see here
it has created a new pivote chart
on another
worksheet it has a sum of the cases and
the sum of The
Debs with that we have covered all the
shortcut keys that can help you speed up
your work in Excel if you think we have
missed out on any shortcut keys then
please put it in the chat section as
well as in the comment section of the
video now let me go back to my
slides now let's have a question and
answer session
where I'll address a few questions so
please feel free to put in your
questions in the chat section of the
video there's one question which I can
see here is how important is Excel for
data
analytics so Microsoft Excel is one of
the top tools for data analysis it is
recommended for those who don't know
programming Excel supports a wide range
of functions to short and filter your
data perform calculations and apply
conditional formatting as well you can
also create P tables and P charts
perform whatif analysis and derive
valuable business insights by
visualizing the data using reports and
dashboards another question I can see in
the chat is is it necessary to memorize
all the shortcut keys not at all you
need not memorize all the shortcut keys
it is hard to remember all of them
shortcut keys are only useful for
performing your tasks better and faster
but but it would be an advantage if you
memorize a few of them also if you
continuously use it while working on
Excel then it will be easier for you to
remember
them let me check a few more
questions okay the next question I can
see here is can Excel be integrated with
other software of course it can be Excel
data can be imported into Microsoft
Access Microsoft Word and PowerPoint use
Microsoft Excel to create tables within
their documents powerbi desktop uses
Microsoft Excel to analyze data
similarly Excel can also be integrated
and used with Microsoft SQL Server
Python and R
programming now let me check if there
are any more
questions okay someone has asked how to
secure information in
Excel so Excel has a cell locking
feature that prevents other users from
changing the information in the cell
Additionally the entire worksheet of
workbook can be password protected if
there are certain parts of the workbook
that should not be seen by unauthorized
people you can place the password on
those parts of the workbook or the
entire workbook
itself now I think I have covered most
of the important questions if you have
any more queries put it in the chat
section our team will reply to it as we
speak you might wonder what it takes to
become an expert data analyst if you are
an aspiring data analyst with at least
one year of domain experience and
looking for online training and
certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more
simply learns postgraduate program in
data analysis from P University in
collaboration with IBM should be your
right choice for more details on this
course head straight to our homepage and
type in postgraduate program and data
analysis or simply click on the link in
the description box below with that in
mind over to our training
experts so what is Su and Excel now you
might want to calculate uh the total sum
of sales right so let us assume that
this is your entire storees sales data
and you wanted to calculate the entire
sum of sales so there is a sum function
in Excel where you just have to you know
select all the sales and apply some
function onto it and you'll get the sum
of all the sales right so with something
like this you'll select all the sales
and then you'll apply a sums function
and you'll get the sum here and average
everything right so this is fine but
what if you just wanted to find the
sales that are happening in only western
region as you can see our column f is
based on region so we have four regions
South West East and Central so your
manager asks you to find the sales
happening in suppose say west region so
how do you calculate it would you
manually go into each cell and if it's w
and calc that will be time consuming
right so what if you had a method which
could do it for you just in a matter of
few steps or few clicks right so that's
exactly sums so it will basically add a
condition calculate the sum of sales
where the region is equals to West
simple to like or similar to Cal query
right so that is exactly what we're
going to do in Excel today that is using
summs now let me add here Sales of West
Region now in the next cell let's add a
summus function remember there are
multiple sum functions in Excel so when
you type in suum you can see so many
options based on sum right you just have
some followed by that you have some if
it is just some if not some ifs today we
are concentrating on some ifs so not
just some if we'll go to some ifs so
we'll be having an option of placing
multiple F conditions there so let's
also try that more on that later now
let's press tab to select our sum FS
function now okay we forgot another
important step so before we apply sufs
we need to convert our table into a
table format yes it looks table but
right now it's not in Tabo format it is
in the format of database we know that
Microsoft Excel considers its data as a
database by default so to convert the
database into table just click anywhere
on the data and press contrl T so that
you'll have a new dialogue box and it
will ask if your table has headers just
make sure that you have Ted in it our
table does have headers so select okay
now our database has been converted into
a perfect table and it's ready for
applying sus function so now you can see
our database has been successfully
converted into a table now let's begin
with our Su ifs now again remember we
are using some ifs here not some if or
some to select Su if and press Tab Key
and we have our sus function now the
first step which column are we looking
at what are we finding out right which
is a sum range what sum do you want for
now we need sum of sales so select the
sales column and we have a simple key
function here let's hold control again
press shift and hold shift together so
we're holding control and shift key
together and now we're pressing lower
Arrow key once yes the entire sales
column has been selected comma Now where
do you want to look so we want to look I
mean which part of the table you want to
fetch right so this is the region part
we want to fetch right now so again hold
control and shift together lower Arrow
key the entire column is selected now
the next last part so we want to look
into the both of the columns that is
sales column and region column now which
type of data you want so for now we want
Western type of data that is the sales
data which is happening only in West
right so we'll select this cell with the
data as West or you can also manually
enter it for now let's select the data
so I'm selecting the cell F7 which has
uh data as West right now let's close
the parenthesis and press enter so there
you go you have the sales happening in
the western region now you can also try
to format it in the form of currency so
let's use uh dollars since it is based
on American states so let's use dollars
so there you go now we are having the
sales data of West now let's try to copy
the same to all the four cells and uh
now here let's type in
East and this can be South right and
this can be your
central there you
go right now you can also copy the same
formula and make minor edits to it so
here instead of f8 you can select uh
East so where is East here and press
enter so you have the sales related to
East now let's try to edit F9 with South
select South Region enter so you have
South sales and what remaining is
Central so let's edit Central as well
and press enter so there you go right
now you have all the separate sales data
from west east south and Central now
again uh you might want a bit more
granularity in data right or in your
reports right like you wanted to find
the sales data happening in West and you
wanted to find out the category based on
only Furnitures so your manager will ask
you okay a fantastic job so now just
give me another minute detail on the
data I want to calculate the sales
happening on West based on category
Furniture right so he wants furniture or
he wants office supplies only right you
can also do that it's not an issue at
all now let's try to copy this cell and
paste it here and sales inest let's add
another input here on
furniture right now you wanted to
calculate the sales happening in west
region only on furniture so you can also
do that now we can use the same same
formula as well just copy paste the
formula here right and you can add few
things here when you try to add a comma
it will automatically generate the next
criteria it is expecting that you are
looking for adding another criteria
right now which column you want you want
category so let's select category you
want to select all the cells same trick
control shift lower key and again press
comma and you want it to select only
uh Furniture so select on furniture cell
there you go now press enter so there
you go we successfully have the sales
data from west region based on category
Only Furniture so that's how you do suf
and XL you can also add a few more
details to it like in Furniture you can
also look only for tables so here you
can see in west region we have furniture
sales data and we have sales data of
West Region based on furniture which
includes only tables you can you can
also do that using sumus function in the
same way all you have to do is select
the subcategory column and select the
cell which has the data as tables so
this is how you use sus in Excel now
without further Ado let's get started
with how to create drop-down list in
Excel now for that we might want to
switch to the Practical mode now we are
on our Excel spreadsheet and here you
can see I'm trying to create an calendar
for the employees in the company where
you might have to you know write down
the day and month and year or week of
your birth date or maybe your joining
date or maybe also your last working day
right this might be useful for all the
employees to you know uh avoid them from
writing it down manually so how do I
create it so it takes a few simple steps
all it takes is some data validation
methods and also there is an exclusive
video specifically made on data
validation in Excel link to which is in
the description box below or you can
search it on our official YouTube
channel now you can see that uh the word
calendar is on the first cell that is A1
but we have four cells below it that is
A3 B3 C3 and D3 so you might want to add
this to all the cells right like may be
in the middle so for that you can do the
option of margin Center also there is a
tutorial on mergin Center about all the
options available in this particular
thing so you can go through that also
and uh yeah we have done the first step
now all we need is day month year and
week so in a calendar or in a month
you'll have days from 28 29 30 or 31
days right so let's create a list or the
drop down menu for that so that whenever
you click it right so whenever you click
on that particular cell you'll have the
list of all the days available right so
let's get started with that let's create
a new
sheet so why are we creating a new sheet
you won't want that all the numbers in
your calendar sheet right over here
right so for that so we are creating a
new sheet and all the data will be
available here so here let's write down
the days first and here the second
number also you can use the option of
Flash Fill so that you can you know uh
reduce the effort here so you can see
the Flash F option over here all you
need to do is select the sales and drag
them down until you get your required
dates right so let's keep it till 31
days there go you have the days so these
will be your days and here now the next
option was month right yeah month and
year now using the same flash F option
you will you know add the months into
your sheet so this will be
Sunday so Excel has this smart flash F
option where you can just drag the data
and everything will be filled according
to your requirements so Sunday to
Saturday now the next one right that is
your
month so same as the before process
we'll create
January
now you can use the flash F option and
all the way up to December now the last
one was the
year so
1990 and
1991 so you can select the cells and
Flash Fill Up to
maybe yeah 2022 should quick good enough
now this is the flashfill option you
have here and also we have an exclusive
tutorial on flashfill Al together you
can go through it for a detailed
explanation as well now coming back to
the original sheet so this is where you
create your drop down list right so
select the cell where you want to add
the drop down list navigate to data and
then here is your data validation menu
so we have a variety of data validation
options here there is an exclusive
tutorial on that you can go through it
for now we'll look into the list option
only because we want to create a drop
down list right so here it will ask for
Source click on the source here the
source bar right now navigate to sheet
number two where we have the days
options select the
range so this will be your range and
select okay also you can add some
message here right what you can do is uh
in case if there is an error or
something right you don't want that to
be happening so all you need to do is uh
write down and select from
dropdown select from dropdown
only
so this could be a message select from
dropdown only the title is Select
options or just
options in case if there's an error you
can write down your title as invalid
data and you can write down a messages
please
select from drop down only
so um in case of someone tries to write
as 32 or 33 to check the Integrity of
your data validation then they will
encounter an error and an error message
and then they must be understanding what
exactly they try to do and if it's
correct or wrong right so this is to
make sure that whatever the data you
enter is correct and valid so okay and
here you can see select from the drop
list only options with option list as
title and let's try to enter 32 right
and when you press enter you will see an
error so the error messages invalid data
please try to select from drop down only
so you can go for a retry and select the
dropdown
right so let's eliminate them and now
select something from the drop down so
let's take it
as maybe 10 right so this is how you
cleared the day one now let's try to do
with the month same data validation
option settings will be list and Source
will
be this
one
think I made a mistake here so let's
cancel this and go back to sheet two and
rename this as our week yeah now coming
back to the month
again it will be a
list and the source will be in sheet 2
navigate to the sheet 2 and select your
range and input message the same
options select from dropdown
only and error alert title will be
invalid
data this one will be
please
select from drop
down
on it's okay and that's done now let's
continue with here as well let's quickly
do the
same
it will be a list Source will be in
shitu
this is your list press okay and lastly
the week same process it will be a list
Source will be in your sheet
two input
message
options
thatle invalid
data it's drop down
only right so your drop down list is
ready now so the month will be anything
So currently we have me and here can be
anything anywhere so let's take it as
1997 and we can be you know the adjacent
week and so what was 10 of May
1997 let's check our
calendars was a
Saturday
so it was a Saturday and that's how you
create drop down list in Excel and if
you want you can also add borders to
your calendar
right so that's how it's done so on my
screen you can see an example Excel
budget template theme so on my screen
you can see a column where you have the
double amount so in the I column we have
all the diit amount what we are spending
for a month and on the right column will
be the balance amount or the running
balance of that for example you can see
that there is a row number five where
the deit amount is 8,000 for a jeans
Levis and it is done through UPI payment
now if I change this value of 8,000 to
4,000 something then you can see that
the running balance will automatically
change you can see that currently the
running balance is 7 23,000 and if I
change this value from 8,000 to 4,000
then all the running balances will
change let's do that so for that let's
press
enter there you go you can see that the
number has been changed successfully and
all the values from the running balance
are also changed until the last day
which is the March
30th now how is this working and not
just that you can see that we have also
included what is the total debit amount
in January and what is the running
balance that is the total available
balance after 1 lakh has been debited
into the account in the month of
February as February income now the
current available balance is
13,200 and the total expense in February
is 1 lakh
14,500 right how am I doing all this
looks so much interesting right now
let's do this practically so for that I
have already created a new sheet and I
have included all the data that we have
used previously the income of that
particular month and all the expenses of
that particular
month now without further Ado let's
begin to implement the Excel budget
template now our first step happens to
be converting all the data into a
natural table so you know that in Excel
all the data values are stored in the
form of a database by default so it
happens to be our duty to convert the
database type table into the pure table
table type table so for that select all
your data and press contr T and there
you go we have an option to convert this
data into a table and remember to check
this particular check box and tell your
Excel that your table has headers so we
do have headers here so now press okay
and your table will be converted into a
natural table now let's type in the
formulas so what are are we doing here
is we are trying to add the sum of J2 +
H3 so which is this particular cell and
removing I3 that is this particular
debit amount so this formula is used for
checking the running balance let's press
enter and there you go so it means that
you received 1 lakh rupees in the month
of January and out of that one lakh you
spend 50 ,000 rupees for something maybe
your educational Lo or something and
then the remaining running balance out
of 1 lakh Rupees is 85,000 rupees now
let's copy the same formula to all the
sales and there you go now the running
balance has been calculated for all the
sales here now remember the monthly
income available balance and debit for
January and Fin balance now let's try to
calculate that for all the three months
so here we have three months that is
January February and March now let's do
a simple calculation to find out the
available balance of that month and the
total debit made by that person in that
particular
month the formula is really simple all
you have to do is use a sum function and
calculate the sum of all these
values and done
right
there you go so the total expense of the
month January is
93,00 rupees now let's calculate the
total dubit of February month same
formula that
is calculating the sum of all the
expenses made in the month of
February
okay now let's also calculate the sum of
all the expenses in the month of
March done so we have the final values
of all the total expenses made in those
particular months now let's calculate
the final balance now I think I forgot
one important thing so before we
calculate the final balance we need to
find out the available balance that is
the available balance after 1 lakh
Rupees is credited into our account and
along with the savings that you have
from your previous month right for that
we have a simple
formula now which all we doing is just
adding the uh income cell with the
balance cell that's all
so there you go now after crediting 1
lakh rupees and adding up the uh balance
of that particular month that is we have
13,200 remaining from the month of
January and the month of February we
have income of 1 lakh so the total
amount is
11,3 no no no it is
13,200 yeah now now we have the final
balance that is the difference between
the available balance and the debit made
in that particular month so in the month
of February we had a total balance of
13,200 and the total debit of 1 lak
14,500 so the final remaining balance is
8,700 similarly the same formula has
been applied for the month of March and
the final balance we have is
37,300 so that's how you implement
budget template in Excel all simple
formulas and you have all the numbers at
your FS so first let's understand what
exactly is misis report in
Excel so Mis stands for management
information system Mis reports provide
data on different categories for
accurate decision making so Mis in Excel
is a procedure to create interactive
report using Microsoft Excel so Mis
reports help management to access the
performance of organization and allow
faster decision making so if you know to
create the Mis reports using various
business intelligence tools such as
Excel then you might find a very good
job opportunity in a wellestablished
company now let us try to learn how to
create Mis report using Excel in a
practical mode so let's get back to the
Microsoft Excel IF getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scaleup by
simply learning click on the link in the
description to know more so here you can
see that I've got some sales data of
various car manufacturing companies and
I've also got some slices so using these
slices I can get the real-time
information from the dashboard so I'll
select an ER from the first slicer and
I'll go into the second slicer and I'll
select a company now I'll select BMW and
SUV type so we have the data of all the
SUV types cars manufactured by BMW car
manufactur in company in the year 2018
now let's start and create something
similar to this
one so how did I create this mis report
let's go through this in a stepbystep
way so on my screen you can see that we
have created a completely new Excel
workbook and we have some sample data
with five rows and 20 columns so this
particular data is based on the
manufacturer year and the car
manufacturing company and the type of
the car manufactured and number of cars
manufactured in that particular year and
also the price of that particular car
now to create Mis reports we need to
play around fav tables so we also have
tutorials on fav tables and you can go
through that in our simply learn YouTube
channel and also we will try to link
those in the description box below now
let's select the entire data and go into
the insert ribbon and there you can see
the first option that is pivot
table so after selecting the pivot table
option it will show this particular
dialogue box where it will ask you for
the range of cells you need to select
and the next one is to create the P
table in the same sheet or a new sheet
so we'll take a new sheet here now
select okay and there you go you have
the pivot table here so first you have
an empty pivot table and on the right
side you can see we have piver table
Fields now you can either drag these
options into the rows and V columns or
you can also click it so now let's drag
and drop these first we will select
here and uh
card followed by that we will take type
quantity and price to
columns so there you go we have our
pivot table now let's select all the
data in the pivot table and again let's
get back to the insert option
and here you can see an option called
pivot chart select that and you will
have various pivot chart options here
now you can select any one which you can
prefer or which you like or whichever
you think can represent your data in a
best way possible so now let's go with
column chart first let's select okay and
we have our column chart over
here now this happens to be our first
chart now let's create a few more charts
s so to create few more charts we'll go
back to the same original data select
again insert and pivot
table now again a new
worksheet so here we have another Mt P
table in the similar way let's drag the
same data into rows and
columns
there you go and again we will select
all the data and create a pivot
chart go to insert option pivot chat and
now let's try to select pie
chat select okay and we have our pie
chart over here now let's try to create
one more same procedure select table
select pivot table then create new
worksheet for the new pivot table and
now drag and drop the
data now let's go to insert
again let's select all the data go to
insert option and pivot chart now let's
try to select the bar chart
select okay and there we have our bar
chart now remember the first chart we
created that is in sheet to this one so
we will try to move all the charts to
this particular table or this particular
worksheet so let's get back to the sheet
number three right click and you can see
an option called pivot chart analyze so
from here you can move the chart select
the option of moving the chart and don't
select the first one select the object
object in option and select the sheet
number to which you want to move this
chart for now we want to move this chart
to sheet number two select that press
okay now we have the chart moved to the
sheet number
two and in the same way let's go to the
sheet number four and let's move this
particular chart to sheet number
two
there you go the chart got moved to
sheet number
two now you can insert the slices so we
have selected the third sheet or third
chart and inside the pivot chart analyze
option we have an option of inserting
the slicer now we will insert the
slicers for here car
and
type now select okay and you will have
all the three slices onto your sheet now
let's rearrange
them so I'm just organizing them in a
neat
way there you go
and you can also customize your designs
for all the
charts so that they look a little more
better now if you see if I make some
changes only one chart will be
interacting for this right so if I
select Ferrari and year 2020 and option
as Sports you can see only one chart is
interacting to these particular slices
why because all these slices are
connected to just one chart here so you
need to make sure that all these slices
are connected to all the three charts
what we created so let's erase all the
filters and select one slicer at a time
right click and you will see an option
of report connections select that and
you see that the connections are only
connected to the pivot table 3 so select
the remaining pivot table as well select
okay and in the same way select the
second slicer select the report
connection option connect pivot table
one and two and select okay and in the
same way the third
one so now all the slices are connected
to all the pivot charts now if you make
some changes here they will respond
automatically in the same way now let's
select the for company the year 2019 and
hashack option and you have all the cars
which were made in the year 2019 from
Ford Company in the segment of
hashack so this was the sample data set
that we worked on now you can also work
on some complex data set such as this
Superstore data
set now one thing you need to make sure
that when you're working with Excel Mis
you need to make sure that all the
macros are disabled on your data set and
you convert the entire data into the
regular table format of excel right now
Excel is considering this particular
data as a database so for that you need
to select all the datar Press contr T
and then convert the entire data in the
form of tabular data and also don't
forget to click this icon which reads my
table has headers so the first row is
the headers now let's select okay and
your entire data will be converted into
tabular form now let's reset this to the
normal type which has the clear color
not all the fancy colors now the entire
data is converted from the dbms to the
tapet form and now you can start
implementing the Mis reports and PIV
tables so that's how you work on Mis
report in Excel power query is an
advanced feature of Microsoft Excel that
allows you to prepare your data for
analysis you can perform numerous text
computations and numerical analysis to
make your data more powerful and
informative Excel power query is a data
preparation and transformation engine it
allows you to carry out the extract
transform and load operations on the
data sets from multiple sources now
let's look at the challenges solved by
power
query earlier in Excel there was
difficulty in data connections Now using
power query you can connect to a broad
range of data sources such as relational
databases web files text CSV Json files
and even fetch data in the cloud volume
variety and velocity are the
characteristics that define Big Data it
was a major problem to handle such data
now power query enables you to transform
your data to an appropriate size it also
allows you to work on any shape of data
from any
Source earlier updating your data and
refreshing it in real time was an issue
using power query a repeatable process
query is adopted to update the data in
real time and in the
future in Excel it was not so easy to
reape transform and manipulate data but
using power query provides a highly
interactive experience and sophisticated
tools to prepare your data
now from Excel 2016 onwards power query
on Windows has been fully integrated
into Excel but in Excel 2010 and 2013
for Windows powerquery is a free addin
you can go ahead and download the link
once installed the power query tab will
be visible in the Excel ribbon now
coming to the features of power query so
Excel power query allows you to clean
transform manipulate and process your
data for analysis it helps you to
automate repetitive task that you want
to do it over and over again you can
search for data sources and make
connections as and when you want Power
query helps you to prepare and shape the
data in the right format for performing
analysis and finally once your data is
ready you can share your findings or use
your query to create interactive reports
and
dashboards now let's have a glance at
the demo that we are going to work on in
this
video so we'll look at how to load data
from different
sources you will understand how to
extract tables from web file so we'll
extract tables present on Wikipedia
Pages then you'll learn how to sort and
filter
data up next you'll see how to group
your data how to split a column into
multiple columns and then pivote and
unpivot your
table then you're going to work on date
columns and make some transformations
understand how to append tables and
merge tables vertically and horizontally
now let's open msxl and start with
importing a simple text file so you can
see here I have my Excel file opened and
in the middle you can see I have my
employee txt file now this is a comma
separated file meaning that the values
are separated by commas as you can see
it here the columns have been separated
by commas and all the values have a
comma between them
now this text file has information about
the name age company and the city to
which the employee belongs to let's see
how easily you can import this EMP text
file into
msxl here I'm using Excel 365 or Office
365 where power query on Windows has
been fully integrated into this version
of excel so what I'll do is first let's
go to the
data Tab and you have this section
called get and transform data so I'll
click on get data under get data I'll go
to from
file and select from text SL
CSV once I click on it it will ask me to
give the location where the file is
there so my file is on desktop I'll
click on power query files and here you
can see I have my employee txt file you
can see the type here it says text
document click on EMP and hit
import now this will take some time to
import the file onto
Excel it's establishing a connection you
can see there you go so here you can see
the file name em. txt you can see the
file origin as I said the D limiter is
comma and we have the data type
detection and here you can see we have
our text file so Excel power query
feature has automatically detected the
column names so we have name age company
and city as our columns and these are
the values now let's hit
load so this will load all the rows and
the columns onto
Excel there you go it was really quick
Excel has automatically loaded our text
file now you can see here we have
another tab called queries and
connections so we have made one query
and have loaded the employee data it
gives a preview also you can see it here
and if needed later you can go to edit
and change some values that we'll see
later now you can use this data to
create simple visualizations so let me
show you how to do it so let's first
select the data and we'll go to the
insert tab under insert tab I'll click
on recommended
charts let's say I want to know how many
employees belong to a particular City so
I'll click on the second chart which
says the count of Name by City And I'll
click on
okay here you can
see we have a nice clustered bar chart
and you can see in Bangalore there were
five employees in Hyderabad we had two
and and in nasik we had one you can see
the count here this is a pivote
table if you go back to our actual data
here you can see in Bangalore we had
Vidya Sonam ainash Varun and himani and
there were two more people from
Hyderabad and one from nask so you can
use the Excel power query feature to
import data onto Excel and make some
visualizations now
if you want to fetch some data that is
present on the web or on the Internet
Excel power query features and
functionalities can help you import
those data as well we will now see how
to import data specifically a table that
is present on the web here I'll be using
a Wikipedia article on the list of
European Cup and UFA Champions League
finals let me show you the page
first so this is my Wikipedia page on
the list of European Cup and UFA
Champions League finals if I I scroll
down you can see all the details here
and I would like to import this table
which has the list of all the finals so
we have columns like season winners
score line Runners up venue and
attendance let's import this table onto
Excel so I'll copy this URL first now
let me open a new sheet I'll go to sheet
one and then on the data tab under the
get data section I'll go to from other
sources and here I have from web which
allows me to import data from the web
either you can follow this path or if
you see here there's an option to get
data from the web if I click on
this it is asking me to enter the URL so
I'll paste the URL of the Wikipedia page
here and let's click on
okay now it's navigating and okay you
can see Power query feature in Excel has
given us a list of tables which you can
see here we have something called as
document there's a key table and here
you can see there's one table which was
extracted from the Wikipedia page and
the table which I'm interested in is
this table which has the list of
European Cup finals you can see it here
Excel power query feature has
automatically detected these rows and it
has given
a list of columns as well you can see
these are the
columns now we'll explore the transform
data tab present in the power query now
if I click on transform data it will
take me to the power query
editor Let me just click on refresh now
this is the most important section now
using the power query editor you can
clean your data filter your data
manipulate your data and make it ready
for
analysis now let's explore a few tabs
available here so we have a Home tab
that has a query section you can see you
can reduce rows manage columns sort the
data transform the data combine
different
tables now there's another tab called
transform which allows you to select
your data type transpose your rows and
columns pivote and unpivot your columns
and here you can see you can find out
some summary
statistics and you can manage your date
values as well now if you want to add
some new columns to your data you can do
that as well and you also have a view
tab now
here if you see the first two rows the
values are the same you can see season
season these are all repeated which we
actually don't need and these are pretty
similar to our column names similarly if
I scroll down you see there are some
rows which have null values so actually
these rows do not add up any value or do
not add any value to our data so we'll
clean this data
first so let's see how to do it now if
you want to remove certain rows in the
table what you can do is go to the Home
tab and under reduce rows click on
remove rows and then choose remove top
rows if I select remove top rows it will
ask me how many rows do you want to
remove from the top you can see it here
I'll give I want to remove the top two
rows now let's click on okay
you will
see that the Excel power query editor
has removed the first two rows and on
the right you can see the steps that
were
applied you can see it here previously
we had these two rows which were
redundant and once we applied the step
it has removed the first two rows
similarly let's go down and remove the
last 1 2 3 4 5 so we are going to remove
the last seven rows from the
table so again I'll go to reduce rows
and click on remove rows now this time
I'll select remove bottom
rows and here I'll
choose I want to delete seven rows from
the table from the bottom I click on
okay if you
see the last seven rows have been
deleted now let me show you the last row
which is this one so the last season of
Ufa Champions League was held in 2020
which is this year and Bayern Munich won
the Champions League against a French
team that was Paris St Germans by a
score of
10 now if you see the last value that is
the
attendance you can see the value is zero
which means there were no Spectators in
the stadium it it was because of the
covid
conditions now let's do some more
manipulation to our data suppose this
time I want to add a new column let's
say a stadium name by extracting values
from the venue column so let me just
show you the venue column so this is our
venue column so the first value is the
stadium name then we have the city in
which the stadium is there and finally
we have
the country name so I want to extract
only the stadium name so you can see we
have some stadiums like Santiago
babo there's bemble
sanso and other stadium so I want to
extract only the stadium names so let's
see how to do that I'll click on the
venue column and go to add column tab
under add column here you can see we
have extract if if I click on this drop
down there's an option to select text
before D limiter so if I choose text
before D limiter here I'll give my D
limiter as comma so everything before
the first comma will be considered as
the stadium name now let me click on
okay now here you can see under applied
steps it says
inserted text before D limiter if I
scroll to the right you can see the last
column has our stadium names let me
double click on this and change this to
stadium name
column and hit enter even this step is
applied here you can see renamed
columns
similarly let's explore a few more
features now I want to add a new Colum
column called stadium city so if you
consider this venue column whatever is
there between the two commas is the
stadium city so for example Santiago
bernabo is in Madrid similarly Wembley
Stadium is in London sanso is in Milan
so these midal values I want to extract
into a new column called as stadium city
so let's see how to do it so click on
the venue column and go to extract and
again I'll select the extract Tab and
here now I'll choose text between D
limits and my first delimiter I'll give
is a
comma and a space you can see here all
the values have a comma and a space and
my end Del limiter will be another
another
comma then I'll click on okay this will
add a new
column to the extreme right of the table
you can see here we have text between D
limitter and it has extracted the
stadium city let me go ahead and rename
this column as
stadium city and hit enter you can see
the applied step
here now
I want to split the score column into
two columns so here we have the score
column
and the left value presents the number
of goals that were scored by the winning
team and the right value presents the
number
of goals that were scored by the losing
team so here I'll split the column into
two columns as winner score and loser
score so what I'll do is Select this
column and go to the Home tab under the
Home tab we have split column I'll
select split column and then choose by
delimiter so automatically Excel power
query detects that this Dash is my
delimiter and I'll split at each
occurrence of the
delimiter let's click on
okay now you can
see the score column has been split into
two it has renamed the column as score
do1 and score
do2 what I'll do is I'll go ahead
and we'll rename this column as winner
score and this will rename it to Loser
score I'll hit enter and I have renamed
it
successfully next let's change the the
winners team and the runners up team
values to uppercase so suppose I want to
change all the values or the club names
of the winners team to upper case so
what I can do is I'll select this column
and go to the transform tab under
transform tab I have this option called
format so here I'll click on format and
then you can see I can change the case
to lower case upper case capitalize each
word so here I want to make all the
winner teams as uppercase I'll select
upper
case there you go we have successfully
converted all the winner team names to
upper case similarly let's do it for the
runner sub team as well so here I have
my runnner sub team I'll go to the
transform tab click on format and select
uppercase now we saw how how to do some
simple manipulation of our data so we
created a few columns split a few
columns now to save all this I have to
go to the Home tab and then click on
close and
upload this will take some time and load
our data onto this Excel
sheet you can see here it's loading the
data this will take a bit of time there
you
go Excel power query feature has
successfully performed some
manipulations on our data some
calculations on our data and then it has
saved the final version and loaded it on
to excel Now using this clean data we
can do some analysis let's say I want to
find the seasons in which the winners
team scored more than three goals so we
have a problem statement at hand where
we want to find the seasons in which the
winner team had more than three goals
scored so what you can do is select any
cell in this data and go to the insert
Tab and click on pivot table here I'll
click on existing worksheet and then
I'll give my location I'll place my P
table somewhere here and click on okay
all right now since I want to know the
seasons I'll drag season on to row and
I'll also drag the winners team
column onto
rows then I'll choose my winner score
under values here you can see we have
the peoe table
ready now we need to filter this table
to see all the winning teams that scored
more than three goals so what I'll do is
I'll select this winner score column and
place it under
filters and here you can see I have my
filter let me click on this drop down
and I'll select multiple items from this
multiple items I'll choose four five and
7even because these values are greater
than three and click on okay here you
can see I have filtered my P table and
to the left you can see the season and
the winner team that had scored more
than three goals in the
finals all right similarly you can
perform some more analysis suppose I
want to know how many times Real Madrid
won the championship so let's see I'll
click on one cell in the data set go to
the insert Tab and click on pivot
table I'll choose existing worksheet and
give my location here let's say I want
to place my pivote table here I click on
okay all right so the question we have
is how many times have Real Madrid won
the championship so I'll choose
the winners team column and place it
under
rows and let's say We'll select the
winner score as
well and let's convert this winner score
from sum to let's say count I click on
okay and since I want to check only for
Real Madrid so what I'll do is I'll go
to the insert tab and I'll insert a
slicer here I'll choose winner teams as
my slicer and click on okay and out of
this I want to choose only Real Madrid
so I'll select Real Madrid you can see
it here Real Madrid have won the
championship 13
times okay let's say you want to
compress your data and remove
unnecessary columns without losing any
information you can can do that using a
feature in the power query editor called
unpivot to perform this task we'll use a
sensus data of India from Wikipedia so
let me first show you the Wikipedia
page so this is my Wikipedia article
which says list of states in India by
passed
population and if I scroll down you can
see it here there's a table which says
by past population from 1947 to
2011 so there are a few few columns like
rank this state or Union territory and
we have population starting from 1951
till 201 which was our last
census here you can see if I scroll
further there are nearly 29 States and
we have seven union territories so we
will extract this table and load into
Excel
first okay so let me click on a new
sheet and we'll follow the same drill
I'll go to my data Tab and click on get
data under get data I'll go to from
other sources and click on from
web here it will ask me to provide the
URL link of the Wikipedia page so I'll
paste the URL here and click on
okay now once I have done that it will
load a few tables onto Excel you can see
there are a few tables here I'll click
on the first one so we have our table
here now let's do some transformation to
this
data this opens in the power query
editor okay I'll click on refresh
first this will take some time to
refresh the entire data okay we are done
now if you see this data
clearly the first row in this table is
not necessary at all because these are
our column names so we also have our
column headers already present so let's
go ahead and delete the first row so
we'll go to the Home tab under remove
rows I'll click on remove top
rows now I'll give
my number of rows as one so we want to
remove the first row only I'll click on
okay you can see the first row has been
deleted if I scroll
further I actually don't need the last
row as well which is the total so what
we can do is we can also remove the last
row from the
bottom so I'll select one click on okay
you can see the step has been applied
and you don't see the last row that was
the total row
anymore so the task that I want to do
here is I want to
compress all these columns which are
basically the population columns
so I'll select my state or Union
territory column and go to the transform
Tab and here I have the option to
unpivot columns so I'll click on this
drop- down and select unpivot other
columns you can see here the step has
been applied and all the population
column from 1951 till 2011 have been
unpivot if you want you can go ahead and
rename these columns let's say I'll
write it as population
column
and let's say this
is I'll rename it to total population
value all right now we are done with our
preparation of data let's go to the Home
tab and click on close and
load now this will take some time to
load the data onto
Excel all right so we have our Census
Data here so first you can see rank one
is uttar Pradesh and we have the
population starting from 1951 till 2011
then we have for
Maharashtra if I scroll down you can see
the other states we have Tamil Nadu
Rajasthan this Karnataka if I scroll
further we have udisha this Telangana
Kerala now if you see here the pop ation
values from 1951 till 2011 for the
telengana state are all na which means
there was no data available now this is
because telengana was only formed in
2014 so there was no census for this
state let's continue with our demo and
let's explore a few more features and
functionalities of powerquery
editor now the next table we are going
to use is an adventure Works customer
table now this data set is provided by
Microsoft for practitioners who want to
learn powerbi Excel or similar
Technologies and want to do some
manipulation some calculation some data
analysis stuff so let me go to a new
sheet and let's import the adventure
Works customer data set it's a CSV file
onto Excel first so I'll go to my data
Tab and click on get data from here I'll
go to from file and
choose from text SL CSV
you can see it here in my power query
files folder I have my adventure Works
customer table I'll select this and
click on
import this will take some time to load
the data set you can see the preview of
the data set here so we have columns
like the customer key we have the prefix
of the customer name the first name the
last name of the customer date of birth
marital status
if I go to the right we have annual
income total children education level
occupation and homeowner column as well
so let's click on transform
data here we'll learn a few more
features of power
query okay we have our data on our power
query editor so first what I'll show you
is let's change the prefix column the
first name column and the last name
column to proper case so you can see it
here the prefix first name and last name
columns are all in upper case now if you
want to change the values to proper case
just hit control and select the three
columns
and go to the transform tab under
transform tab you have
format so if click on format here you
can see we have lower case uppercase now
proper case is to capitalize each word
so I'll click on capitalize each
word you can see it here now we have
converted the prefix first name and last
name column into prop case The Next Step
I'm going to show you is let's merge all
the three columns the prefix column the
first name column and the last name
column into one full name column so what
I'll do is I'll select the three columns
and then let's go to add column and
under add column we have this option
called merge columns let's hit merge
columns okay now it's asking you to give
the separator I'll select my separator
as a
space and click on
okay okay so before click on okay I want
to change my new column name from merged
to Let's say full
name and now let's click on
okay you can see here it says inserted
merged column and if I go to my right
you can see it here we have a full name
column now if you want to shift the
location of the full name column you can
do that as well just hold this and keep
on dragging to the
left this will move the
entire table to the right and you can
place it wherever you want so I want to
place it let's say
here
okay now actually I don't want all these
columns so let's delete it so click on
this and I'll right click and click on
remove you can see we have removed the
prefix column similarly let's remove the
other two columns you can either right
click and do or go to the Home tab and
then select remove
columns all right
now let's say we want to add a domain
name column from AWS customers by
extracting the characters between at
theate
andom so actually I'm talking about the
email address from this email address we
want to create a new column called as
domain name for that we'll extract
characters that are present between at
theate and doom so let's see how to do
it I'll select the email address column
and then I'll go to add column under add
column I'll click on extract and this
time we want to extract between two
delimeters so I'll select text between D
limitter and I'll give my starting D
limiter as at the
rate and my endd limiter would be
Doom now let's click on okay so this
will insert a new column to the extreme
right you can see we have our domain
name let's go ahead and change the
column name to domain name and hit
enter all right you can see the step has
been
applied now we are done
with our preparation of customers table
let's just go to the Home tab and click
on close and
load so all the transformation that we
did in the power query editor will
reflect here so you can see we have our
full name
column and if you see we have our domain
name as
well okay using the power query editor
you can perform some statistical
analysis now let's explore those
statistical features for this we'll be
using another data set called Adventure
Works product data set set again this
data set is also provided by
Microsoft so let's go to the new sheet
and here I'll go to the data tab click
on get data under from files I click on
text SL CSV here you can see we have
Adventure Works products I click on
import let's click on transform data
so we have our data loaded onto the
power query
editor the data is mostly clean so let's
not alter this data let's straight away
go ahead and explore some of the
statistical features that we have here
now let's say if you want to find the
total number of product names in the
product table
we have this product name column and say
if you want to find the total number of
product names in the table how to do it
so what you can do is click on this
product name column then go to the
transform tab now in the transform tab
you have an option called statistics
click on this drop-down and select count
values now this will open another
window that will return the total number
of products in the table you can see the
value here it says
293 now to move back to the query editor
we have to cancel this step here so
let's just click cancel or close we are
back again all right now let's say you
want to calculate the average product
price from the product table so if I
move to the right you have a column
called Product
price so let's see what is the average
product price from the product table so
I I'll select this product price column
go to the transform tab under statistics
I'll select average so this will give me
the average product price which
is
4373 you can consider any unit you want
let's say this is in dollars now again
we have to cancel this step to move
back
okay now if you want to find the maximum
and minimum product price you you can do
that as well so let me select my column
product price and go to the transform
tab under the transform tab we'll click
on this statistic drop-down and let's
say I'll select minimum so this will
give me the minimum product price which
is
2.29
similarly if you want to find the
maximum product price so select this
product price column go to the transform
Tab and then choose
maximum so this is the maximum product
price in the product table we have let's
cancel this
step okay now you can also round the
product cost and product price column to
two decimal places so if I show you both
the columns you have your product cost
and you have the product price column
you can see the floating values or the
decimal points are not constant it's
varying so let's limit it to two decimal
places
what you can do is Select both the
columns and then go to the transform tab
in the transform tab you have here
rounding I'll click on this drop- down
and select
round now here I'll give my decimal
places as
two if I click on okay you can see here
both the columns the product cost and
the product price column have been
rounded up to two decimal places
I can scroll down you can see all the
values have been rounded up to two
decimal places all
right now let's say you want to add a
column called discount price column by
multiplying 0.9 to the product price
column and let's say you also want to
round that new column to two decimal
places so how to do
it so we want to give a discount of 10%
so so I'll select this product price
column go to add column and then I'll
choose custom
column here we'll write a
formula so I'll give my new column name
as discount
price and my formula would
be I'll select product price I'll click
on insert and then I'll multiply this
product price by 0
.9 so this will give me my 10% discount
on the product price and click on
okay you see here we have a new column
added which is Discount price
so if the product price is
34.99 if you give a 10% discount it's
31.4914
places to two so I'll go to the
transform tab under rounding I'll click
on
round let's see I'll give two and click
on okay so even this has rounded the
discount price column to two decimal
places now we are done with our
mathematical operation on this product
data set so we saw how to find sum
average count how to round of values how
to add a new custom column
so let's go ahead and close it and load
it onto
Excel you see here we have our new
product table added here and the last
column if you see it's the discount
column that we
added okay now it's time for us to
explore another feature so we'll use a
table called Adventure Works calendar
table which has basically a date column
and let's say
how using power query you can prepare
that data as well and make some
manipulations some
calculations so let me go ahead and
import Adventure Works calendars table
again this data set is provided by
Microsoft so I'll go to my new
sheet and I'll go to the data tab click
on get data and from here I'll click on
from text / CSV and you can see I have
my calendar table here I click on import
now this will open in the query
editor you see here this data set has
only one column which is a date column
so let's click on transform data okay
now if you see here the first row is
actually the column name so let's do the
transformation here let's push this as
the column name so I'll go to the Home
tab and under Home tab you have this
option called use first row as headers
I'll select
this you see here we have the column
name as date
now before making any operation let's
see if all the fields are
available you see here if I click on the
date drop down year month quarter week
dat day everything has been shaded out
and I can't access this the reason is is
the date settings are not correct so
we'll change the regional settings let
me show you how to do it so we'll go to
file and I'll select options and
settings and go to query
Options under query options we have
something called as Regional settings
here under Regional settings we'll
select English United States instead of
English
India so I'll just scroll down and here
we have English United States and I
click on okay now once this is done I'll
go to my data type and I'll select date
as my data type I'll choose replace
current okay now you can see my date
column has been formatted if I go to the
date tab you can see I have access to
all this now let's do some operations on
this date
column let's say you want to find the
earliest and the latest date from ew
calendar table or the adventure Works
calendar table so what you can do is
Select this
column go to date drop down under
transform and here we have the option of
earliest and latest so if I click on
earliest this will show you the last
date which was 1st of January 2015 15
let me close this similarly you can see
the most recent date I'll go to the date
drop down and click on latest and you
have 30 June 2017 as the latest date
I'll close
this now let's add a new column see D
name start of the week and others so
I'll select my date
column go to add column here under add
column I
have my option
to select the D name the week name and
others so I'll click on this date drop
down and under D let's say I want to
choose name of
D this Returns the D
name
similarly let's
say I'll want to find out
the start of the
week you can see we have the start of
the week column or start of week column
now one thing to notice here
is in this power query editor the week
starts on a Sunday now suppose you want
to start your week on a Monday you can
do some Transformations on this formula
tab so here in the formula bar you can
add a one here to make sure your week
start starts on a Monday so if I hit
enter you will see all these values will
change you can see it's 28 4 and 11 this
will become 29 5 and 12 let's hit enter
you can see it here your start of the
week is on a
Monday now there's another method to
make sure your week starts on a Monday
let's cancel this
step okay I have to insert it once again
so I'll go to date
and here I'll choose start of
week now the week starts on a Sunday so
one more method is
to add day dot Monday you can see
automatically powerquery is giving me a
suggestion so I'll hit tab to finish it
and I'll hit enter now you can see the
values have changed and our week starts
on a
Monday now let's say we want to add a
few more columns like start of month
name of month start of year and the year
value so you can just click on the date
column or select the date column go to
the transform
tab okay not the transform tab let's go
to the add column Tab and here let's say
I'll choose ear so we have all the ear
values and
similarly let's say I want to know the
start of the year
here now you can do a few more
Transformations let's say I want to know
the
month now here it gives us one which
means January that's February March and
so on and so
forth let's say we'll do one more I'll
click on this go to
my
date drop down and here I'll choose
let's say I want to
know the day of year
all right now we are done with all our
transformation and preparing our data on
a date field so let me just go to the
Home tab I'll click on close and
load now this will load
the data set onto Excel you can see it
here we have the data ready now you can
use this data to make some
analysis draw a pivote table draw a
pivote chart and do a whole lot of
things now while working on a project it
is possible that not all your data will
be in a single file it could be stored
in multiple files so it's important to
combine and bring all your data together
now we will see how to join your data
vertically I have my data present in a
CSV folder so let me show you the folder
first so this is my CSV folder let me
open it and I have some files these are
named as project 1 2 3 4 and five let me
open just one of the project files it
has a very small quantity of
data you can see it has a month column
and an amount column let me close
this and let me show it to you again
let's open project
4 all the files have the same number of
columns you can see this also has a
month column and an amount
column now we'll combine all this data
together and load it into Excel let's
see how to do it so I'll open a new
sheet and I'll go to my data Tab and
click on get data then I'll go to from
file and this time I'll choose from
folder now this will ask me to give the
folder location or the path location
where my CSV files are so I'll choose
browse and here you can see I have my
CSV file I'll just double click on it
and click on open now it has selected
my file path or the folder path then
I'll click on
okay you can see these are the files you
have project 1.
XLS project 2. XLS and so
on I'll click on this combine drop-down
and I'll hit combine and
transform now this will give you the
preview of one of the data
files you will see it
now you can see it here it says sheet
one
okay now it's processing all the data
files present in that CSV
folder and this will be uploaded onto
our power query
editor now you can see here on the power
query
editor all my data files have been
combined vertically here you can see the
month
column on the extreme right it's the
amount column and to the extreme left we
have the source name or the source file
where the data came from so first is
Project one then we have project two if
I scroll down we have project 3 files
project 4 and similarly we have project
5 now this is one way in which you can
merge your tables vertically so we are
done with it let's just go to the Home
tab and click on close and
load all the Transformations that were
applied you can see it here we have our
final
table and we have
successfully
combined five Excel
files again you can also join your data
horizontally this would be like an SQL
join where the data is present in
multiple files or sheets based on a
common key column you can join the
tables so you can perform a left join a
right join and inner join based on the
problem that you are trying to solve so
let's merge two tables based on a column
I'll show the data set first it's an
Excel file which has three
worksheets so here is my Excel file
which we'll be using to merge our data
horizontally you can see there are three
worksheets the first one is year 11
which has data regarding the student
name the gender of the student and the
course the student had opted for
similarly we have another for 2012 or
year 12 we have the student name gender
as well as the
course and finally we have a courses
table or a courses sheet which has all
the details regarding the course so we
have the course name the teacher who
teaches or teacher who taught that
course we have the lesson type the the
number of credits and the assignment
type now we'll use this data sets to
load it onto Excel using power
query so I am on my Excel sheet let's
just open a new sheet I'll go to the
data Tab and here I'll click on get data
and this time I'll choose from Excel
workbook and I'll select my file which
is students and courses I click on
import so we'll just see how to import
two tables and join them horizontally so
let me first select the courses sheet
and I'll click on transform
data now this has loaded the courses
table onto powerquery editor the table
looks fine we have the course column
teacher everything is fine now let's
load one more table and then we'll merge
it
so here under the Home tab you have a
section called new source I'll click on
file I'll again select my students and
courses and click on
import and this time let's choose
another table let's say year 11 which
has the column name as student gender
and course I click on
okay it has successfully loaded this
table onto power query
editor now if you see this the first row
is actually
are column names so I'll go to the Home
tab and select use first row as headers
so this will push the first row to the
column names you can see we have done it
successfully we have my student name the
gender column and the course
column now let's merge it so if you see
here in the Home tab we have a section
called merge
queries let's click on this drop down
and select merge
queries here I have my table which is
year 11 and let's choose one more table
that
is
courses now the kind of join I'll choose
as left outer join which means it will
will take all the rows from the first
table and matching records from the
second
table here I need to select the common
key column so if you see both the tables
we have the course column as the common
key column so I'll select this and now
you can see there's a tick mark which
means it has selected the rows and the
columns successfully you can see it says
the selection matches 175 or 175 rows
from the first table and let's click on
okay let's just expand
this and click on
okay if I scroll to the right you can
see I have successfully merged both the
tables now if you want you can remove
unnecessary rows or columns suppose if
you see I have the course column from
the year 11 table and here also I have
the course column now this is redundant
let's just remove one of the columns
I'll just select this column I'll go to
remove columns and I'll select remove
columns okay the rest looks fine we have
successfully marched both the tables by
using a left outer join let's just click
close And
load
now this will take some time to load our
data onto Excel you can see it here we
have successfully loaded it onto
Excel now we are done with our demo
part now let's just see what all we have
done in our demo so I'll go to my first
sheet here you can see we had imported a
simple text file first and then we
plotted
a graph which is a pivote chart then you
saw how to
upload a file from the web so here we
imported a UFA Champions League table
which was present on Wikipedia and then
we plotted some graphs and charts you
can see we made some analysis using p
tables and then we imported another web
file which was based on a population
data data and we use the unpivot option
or the unpivot feature in the power
query to reduce the number of
columns then we made some calculations
to our customer table which was from
Adventure works then we used another
table called the products table here we
saw some statistical calculations and we
added a column called discount price
where we used conditional
operations and then you saw how we
manipulated
a date
column and then we saw how to append and
merge multiple tables as we speak you
might wonder what it takes to become an
expert data analyst if you are an
aspiring data analyst with at least one
year of domain experience and looking
for online training and certifications
from prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts then
search no more simply learns
postgraduate program in data analysis
from per University in collaboration
with I BM should be your right choice
for more details on this course head
straight to our homepage and type in
postgraduate program in data analysis or
simply click on the link in the
description box below with that in mind
over to our training experts let's begin
by understanding what is a pavot
table a pavot table is a tool that
summarizes and reorganizes selected
columns and rows of data in a
spreadsheet to obtain a desired
report it does not actually change the
spreadsheet data it simply pivots or
turns the data to view it in different
perspectives pivot tables are especially
useful with large amounts of data that
would be timec consuming to calculate
manually now let's understand the
different components of a pivot table so
there are four main components first we
have rows when a field is chosen for the
row area it populates as the first
column in the pivot table similar to The
Columns all row labels are unique values
and duplicates are removed columns is
the second component when a field is
chosen for the column area only the
unique values of the field are listed
across the top then we have values each
value is kept in a pivot table cell and
displays the summarized information the
most common values are sum average
minimum and maximum finally we have
filters filters apply a calculation or
restriction to the entire table so let's
jump over to Microsoft Excel and let me
show you the data set that we will use
in this demo so with India being ready
for its 16th census in
2021 that is next year it is a good time
for us to analyze India's last census
data from 2011 and see where different
states and cities across India stood in
terms of population literacy and other
socioeconomic factors we will analyze
this data by creating different pivot
tables in Excel and explore some of its
features so let's begin first I'll show
you one of the features that Excel
offers us so suppose I click on any cell
and hit contrl + Q you can see our
entire table is selected and at the
right bottom there's an option of quick
analysis now you can see by default
Excel has prompted certain features such
as formatting we have charts totals and
there's one more called tables now Excel
by default has created some P tables for
us now the first one you say sum of
district code by state names next we
have sum of sex ratio by state name then
we have some of child sex ratio some of
male graduates and some of female
graduates by state name and there are
others before creating our pivote table
so let's have a final look at our data
set so First Column you see is the city
column so there are different cities
from different parts of India then we
have the state code we have the state
name district code we have the total
population followed by male and female
population
next you can see we have the total
literates from each City then we have
the male and female literates next we
have the sex ratio then we have the
child sex ratio next we have total
number of graduates and finally you can
see we have male and female graduates so
using this table we'll create several
pivote
tables now first of all let's create a
peot table to find the total population
for each state and sort it in descending
order so you can see here we have the
problem statement so our first P table
will have the total population for each
of the states in descending order so to
create a p table you can click any cell
in your data go to the insert Tab and
here left you can see we have the option
to create a pivote table so let me
select pivote table now my range is
already selected the entire table and
here I'll choose existing worksheet
because I want to place my pivote table
in the same worksheet and I'll give my
location I'll point to cell Q5 now let
me click
okay you can see the peot table Fields
appears here on the right now since we
want to find the total population for
each state so what I'll do is I'll drag
my state name onto rows so here in our p
table you can see we have the different
state names listed now we want the total
population for each of these states so
in the field list I'll search for total
population which is this one and drag it
under
values you can see we have a sum of
total population for each of these
states by default Excel will sum any
numeric column you can always change it
to to average minimum maximum anything
you want now we want to sort this column
in descending order so I right click go
to sort option and choose Zed to a that
is largest to
smallest you can see here in 2011
Maharashtra had the highest number of
population or the total population in
Maharashtra was the highest then it was
utar Pradesh we had Andra Pradesh and if
I come down we have nagaland and man and
nicobar Islands towards the end so this
is a simple P table that we created now
the next problem we have is we want to
find the total sum of literates in each
City belonging to a certain state so
let's see how to do it I'll click on any
cell go to insert and here I can click
on pivot table my range is selected I'll
choose existing worksheet and give my
location which is Q5
I click on
okay now here we want to find the total
sum of literates so what I'll do is
first let me drag total literates column
to values you have the total sum of
literates from all the
states next I want to see the sum of
total literates based on states and
cities so let me first drag state name
onto rows and then will dra City onto
rows
you can see here we have our pivote
table
ready to the left of the peot table you
can see we have the state names and the
cities per state and on the right you
can see the total number of literates
from each City if I scroll down we have
Assam then you can see we have
Bihar and if I keep scrolling we have
all the states harana himanchal Pradesh
there Jammu and Kashmir which has now
become a union territory
we have jarand Karnataka and other
states as well moving
on okay so the next thing we want to see
is what is the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state with that
we also want to find the states that had
the highest and lowest sex ratio in
2011 so let's create a p table for this
I'll click on any cell go to insert
choose P table click on existing
worksheet I'll select cell Q five and
click on
okay now since we want the average sex
ratio and the child sex ratio so first
I'll drag those columns either you can
manually scroll and drag it or here you
have the option to search for it so if I
look for child you can see we
have the same column listed can just
drag it from there let me delete this
and I also want the sex ratio so I'll
place it on top of child sex ratio next
we want to see it based on different
states so what I'll do is I'll take
state name and put it under rows so here
you can see we have our P table ready on
the left you can see we have the
different state names listed and on the
right we have the values now we want to
find the average Now by default Excel
will sum the numeric columns you can see
it tells you sum of sex ratio and child
sex ratio so what you can do can click
on this drop down and go to Value field
settings and here summarize values by
you can choose average you can see the
custom name it says average of Sixx
ratio click on
okay our entire column is now
giving us the average sex ratio
similarly for this column let me convert
it into average I'll again click on the
drop down go to Value field settings
click on average and click
okay and you can see here we have the
average of child sex ratio for each of
the states now the next question says
which states had the highest and lowest
sex ratio so we'll consider this column
so we'll sort it in any order you want
you can do it either ascending or
descending let me sort it in descending
order you can see we have our column
sorted now so in
2011 Kerala had the highest sex ratio
and if I scroll down to the bottom you
can see himanchal Pradesh had the lowest
which is around
[Music]
818 up next let's explore one more
feature of peot table so suppose you
want to see the top or bottom few rows
of a peot table you can do that as well
so here we have a question at hand we
want to find the top three cities with
the highest number of female graduates
so let's see from the entire pivote
table how we can filter the top three
cities so I'll go to insert click on the
pivote table option go to existing
worksheet click on Q5 and hit okay
now since we want to find the top three
cities I'll drag City column onto rows
and then we want the female graduates so
in the search bar I'll look for
female and I'll choose this column that
is female graduates and drag it here
onto values so I have the sum of female
graduates for each of the Cities now
since we want to find the highest number
of female graduates in in the top three
cities so let me first sort this
column I'll sort it in descending order
now we have it sorted now from this you
can say that Delhi greater Mumbai and
bangaluru are the top three cities but
it's displaying all the cities for us so
let's filter only the top three so what
you can do is right
click and go to filter under filter you
have the option of top 10 I'll select
this here I only want the top three so
either you
can go down like this or you can
directly type
three your column is already selected
let me just click on okay there you go
we have the required pivote table ready
and it only displays us the top three
cities with the highest number of female
graduates now the next thing we want to
see is how to use a slicer in a peot
table so we have a question here What's
the total population for all the cities
in Rajasthan and Karnataka so let's
create a p table for this and see how
you can use a slicer to filter the
table click on existing I'll click on a
location this time
q6 click okay now since I want the total
population so I'll drag total population
onto values and then I'll s select the
city onto row and then the state name
also I'll place it on top of City so you
have in the pivot table all the states
and their cities and on the right you
can see the total population for each of
these cities but our question is we want
to find only for Rajasthan and Karnataka
now for that what you can do is go to
insert
and create a slicer either you can
create from this option or you can go to
pivote table analyze option and here you
have the option to create or insert a
slicer I click on this and since we want
to slice the table based on state that
is Rajasthan and Karnataka I'll choose
state name as my slicer
field you can see this is my slicer here
now
you only want the data for Rajasthan and
Karnataka so I'll search for these two
so here we have Karnataka so let me
select Karnataka
first and I also want for
Rajasthan so let me select Rajasthan
also you can see in our P table we only
have data for Rajasthan and
Karnataka so this pivote table shows you
different cities from Karnataka and the
total sum of population from each of the
cities and similarly we also have for
Rajasthan moving ahead now we will see
another very interesting feature of
pivot that is how you
can create percentage contribution of a
table for example we have a question
here what's the percentage contribution
of male and female literates from each
state
now we want to see in terms of
percentage and not as sum or average
let's do that I'll create my pivote
table click on
existing and I'll select an empty
cell okay now here since we want to find
the percentage contribution of male and
female literates so first I'll
drag M literates onto values followed by
female literates on two values by
default it has summed up the male litat
and female litat value and also I want
to drag State
column to
rows so here you can see the sum of male
literates and female literates per state
I want to convert this as percentage
contribution so what we can do is I'll
select any cell and I'll right click and
I'll go to so value as and here I have
the option to select percentage of grand
total so I'll select
this you can see we have the percentage
contribution of male literates through
the total now if I sort this you will
get to know which state contributed or
has the highest percentage
contribution so we have Maharashtra for
male
literates then we had utar prades in
2011 if I come
down we had migala nagaland and Andaman
and nicobar
Islands as two states which had little
or minimal contribution to male
literates similarly let's do it for
female literates I'll go to so value as
and select percentage of grand
total so you can see here also
Maharashtra utar Pradesh then Gujarat
and all had the highest percentage
contribution to female
literates so this is another good
feature to convert your data and see it
in terms of
percentage now moving ahead let's say we
want to find the bottom three cities
from each state that had the lowest
female graduates we can do that as well
I'll go to insert click on
pivot go to existing worksheet select an
empty worksheet and click on
okay now now since I want to see based
on States as well as cities so let me
drag the state name first onto row and
let's drag the city column onto
rows
next we want female graduates so let me
look for female graduates in the field
list I'll drag it onto
values now we have the list of states
and the respective cities and to the
right of the peot table you can see the
sum of female graduates from each
City now first I'll sort this column
I'll right click go to sort and click on
sest to largest now we have sorted our
female graduates
from shortest or smallest to largest now
since I want to find the bottom three
cities from each state I'll come come to
the cell right click go to filter and
select top 10 now
I'll replace top 10 with bottom and I
want the bottom three cities from each
state I have my column selected that is
some of female graduates if I click on
okay you can see here some of the states
don't have three cities so you can see
andan and nicobar islands has only one
city that is Cod player while the
remaining you can find the bottom three
cities with the lowest number of female
graduates so Andra Pradesh had these
three in Assam we had Naga then there
was tiar and CA similarly if I come down
in harana we have palwal kathal and
zind if I come further here you can see
for Karnataka there gangavati this ranii
benur and the scholar similarly you can
see for Kerala as
well
now moving
ahead now in the next example I'll tell
you how you can create a calculated
field or a calculated column in Excel
with the help of a pavot table so in a
pavot table you can create or use custom
formulas to create calculated fields or
items calculated fields are formulas
that can refer to other fields in the
pivote table calculated Fields appear
with other value fields in the pivote
table like other value Fields a
calculated Fields name May proceed with
sum of followed by the field name so
here we have a sales table that has
columns like the items which has
different fruits and vegetables and
those have been categorized as fruits
and vegetables we have the price per kg
and this is in terms of
rupees and we have the quantity that was
sold now let's see if you want to find
the sales for each item in the table you
can create a calculated field so your
sales column is going to be the product
of price per kg and quantity so let me
show you how you can do that with the
help of a peot table I'll create a p
table
first click on an empty cell hit okay
now if you see on the top under P table
analyze and under calculations we have
the option Fields items and sets if I
click on this drop down I get the option
to create a calculated field or insert a
calculated field I click on this I'll
give my field name as
sales and I'll select my
formula I'll first click on price per kg
and hit insert field I'll give a space
hit shift 8 to give the product symbol
and then I'll double click on quantity
now this is my formula for sales that is
price per kg multiplied by quantity I'll
click on ADD and I click on okay if you
see here there's a calculated field that
is present in the pivote table fields
which is Sals but it did not add it to
our original table or original table is
the same but here we have added a
calculated field which is present only
in the pivote table list now we can use
this it has already taken it under
values now let's say I want to find the
sum of sales for each
item under each category you can see it
here we have our category fruit and we
have our category vegetable and under
that we have different items like apple
apricot banana similarly in vegetables
we have broccoli the scrots corn
eggplant and others so this is how you
can create a calculated field in a
pivote table now there's one more good
feature that Excel offers us in pivote
table is to create a pivote chart so you
can use your pivote table and create
different charts so I'll show you how to
do that if I go to
insert here I have the option of
recommended charts I click on this Excel
gives me some default charts which you
can use let's say I'll select
this let me drag it a bit to the right
here you can see I'll close this pivote
field list this is a nice bar chart that
Excel has created this is called a
pivote chart now here you can see the
category fruits and vegetables and the
different fruits and vegetables are the
items in the y axis you can see the
total Sals if you see from the graph
guava meet the highest amount of Sals
now if I sort this let's sort this first
you can see it here fruit guava meet the
highest amount of sales now since I
sorted and changed my P table the peot
chart also automatically gets updated
similarly there are other charts also
that you can create let's go to the
insert Tab and let's click on
recommended charts again let's look for
a pie chart so this is a pie chart that
you can create let me click on okay so
here is our pie chart and each Pi
represents a certain item and the pi
that has the highest area represents it
had the highest amount of seals in this
case you can see it is quava and
similarly we have other items as well
this is fruit
banana that's
corn and we have spinach and
others let's explore a few other charts
so first I'll click on my pivot table go
to insert and under recommended charts
let's now select a line chart if I hit
okay move it to the right so this is a
line chart you can see it starts from
guava which had the highest amount of
sales then it
drops and in the x-axis you can see the
different items similarly when it starts
with the vegetables brool made the
highest amount of sales with 2,800
rupees and our lowest was
eggplant at 9900 rupees for fruits
papaya sold the least at 700 rupees
let's take another chart I'll go to
insert under recommended charts let's
see this time we'll see a bar chart now
this is
a horizontal bar chart and not a
vertical one we just saw a vertical
column chart like this this is an
horizontal bar chart now you can always
in increase and decrease the size of
these
charts let's explore a last chart let's
take the area chart for now so this is
an area chart again it looks similar to
the line chart it starts with guava
which had the highest amount of seals
similarly papaya under fruits had the
lowest amount of seals under vegetables
it was broccoli and finally eggplant
made the lowest amount of sales under
veget
now let's go to our first sheet and
summarize what we have done in this demo
for pivot tables in Excel so we had our
data this is a 2011 Census Data from
India we had the different cities the
state names and we had the total
population total literates female
literates male literates we had the sex
ratio total graduates and other
information so we began by understanding
how to create cre a simple pivote table
where we calculated the total population
for each state and sorted it in
descending order we found that
Maharashtra utar Pradesh had the total
population in
2011 then we saw another preo table
where we calculated the total sum of
literates in each City belonging to a
certain state so you can see we had the
different state names and the cities
under each
state
then we saw another feature where you
could calculate the average of a certain
numerical column so here we calculated
the average sex ratio and the child sex
ratio for each state and found out which
one had the highest and lowest sex
ratio after that we saw how you could
find or filter
tables we saw how to find the top three
cities with the highest number of female
graduates we found out that Delhi
greater Mumbai and bangaluru but the top
cities with highest number of female
graduates next we saw how to use Slicer
in a p table so we sliced our table
based on Rajasthan and Karnataka State
and saw the total population for all the
cities in Rajasthan and
Karnataka in the next
sheet we explored another feature that
was to find the percentage contribution
of male and female literates from each
state then here we saw how to find out
the bottom three cities for each state
having lowest female graduates now one
thing marked that some of the states did
not have three cities for example
Andaman had only one city that was Port
player but the others we found out the
bottom three cities that had the lowest
female graduates finally we looked at
how to create a calculated field in a
pivote table so we saw how to create a
calculated field called sales
and then we explored how to create
different charts and graphs so this was
an area chart that we saw there a column
chart we also saw or looked at a bar
chart that was a horizontal bar chart
similarly we saw how to create a pie
chart as well and with that we have
reached to the end of the session on
Excel fil course should you need any
assistance on PPD data set project code
and other resources used in this session
please do let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be happy to help you as soon as
possible until next time thank you stay
ahead and keep learning stay tuned for
more from s staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including including data science
cloud computing cyber security AI
machine learning or digital marketing
designed in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here